Uh-oh.
Uh-oh, there it is.
Silly.
Welcome today to Devil May Cry 2.
Hello.
Hi.
I don't know who to play.
Who do I play as?
Wait, where is my controller?
There it is.
Dante?
Let me do a poll.
Start a poll.
Who do I play as?
Dante.
What's her name?
Lucia?
It won't make too much of a difference.
Do two playthroughs.
Obviously, that's the correct answer.
Two playthroughs.
First is Dante.
Pick Lucia.
As a fan of DMC2, I personally find the playthrough with Lucia to be more enjoyable.
The game is not the greatest.
At least you admit that.
You look more derpy than usual, Minky.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Oh, so many people are saying pick Dante.
What?
Everybody knows that you pick the sexy ladies.
So you have a nice butt to look at when you're running around.
It's my birthday.
Shin Solar!
Praise the sun!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday Shin Solar.
Happy birthday!
Back to your regularly scheduled Minto.
The poll has spoken.
It is Dante's hour.
Would you like to continue?
Yes.
Sorry to hear the news about one of the buildings in Akiba.
I was fortunate enough to get some pictures there a couple of days ago.
I wish it was just one building in Akiba.
I also wish it wasn't hotels.
They just built another Appa.
Oh yeah!
Grandma!
Oh my god.
I couldn't read that.
It's too fast.
I can't read it.
Oh yeah, baby!
Who's gonna use the sword, huh?
Evan and Ivory.
All the way, baby.
Oh, you guys aren't watching...
Hold on.
I knew this was gonna happen.
And I was like, when I select a choice, make sure I select...
Make sure I also make it so that they can see the screen.
Hold on, maybe it will show up.
There it is!
Wait, hold on.
There we go.
You guys missed all the best parts!
Oh my god, the building is pregnant.
Oh, it's a girl!
Spoilers?
How is this bad?
It looks so good, you guys!
This looks so good!
Lanny, happy birthday!
Wait, it's your birthday too.
I get to catch a mainstream on my birthday.
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Leonie!
Happy birthday!
Not putting the game on the screen is better.
Oh, here we can watch from the beginning, guys.
Now, just ignore the last 3 minutes and put this over it instead.
DMC2 is one of the games of all time.
I'm here to just get through it.
I'll be honest.
People have been saying it's so bad.
I want to make my own opinions, but also...
It would be so bad to have DMC1, DMC3, DMC4, DMC5...
I don't think I'd be able to handle not having 2 in the list.
It would be driving me crazy.
I have to remember how to play the game.
We're flipping in the air!
Oh my god, it's Mothra.
Wow, Monkey!
Minky!
Minky, Minky and Devil May Cry.
OK, we get to see the building give birth again.
I'm on fire in Malaysia!
When I was a kid, I got 2 games a year for Christmas.
Birthday and Christmas.
I chose Devil May Cry 2 as one of those games and it still hurts inside.
How would you have known?
It's going to be awesome to see this become your favorite entry in the franchise after months of people telling you about it.
You'll hate it.
Wouldn't that be awesome if I'm just like, what are you talking about everybody?
DMC2 is peak!
It's cinema!
OK, here we go.
We're just jumping right into it everybody.
Darkness.
Oh my god.
Different cutscenes?
Nah, I don't think I'll do it.
I'm sorry.
Sparda!
Oh my god, they got boobs.
These are real harpies.
Oh my god.
Oh yeah.
How's the audio by the way?
A bit low.
There we go.
Heads or tails?
Tails, because you're always going to see my behind.
Good job Dante.
Dante looks so good in this game though.
He needs a few more belts.
Cute!
She's so cute!
I understand I play DMC2 after 1 because I like to play in chronological order.
Yeah.
Oh we're going to...
Brazil?
Alright, here we go.
What system was this for?
PS2?
PS2 again.
My ex-friends recommended me this game.
Gonzalo!
Thanks for a year!
I got 0 rorbs, but that won't be for so long.
Can I kill this thing?
Nope.
Can I slice it?
How do I use my sword?
Oh there we go.
Ah hi, I'm a ruler.
Is it acquired taste?
Ok.
I thought it was going to ask me what kind of game mode I wanted to play on.
Like easy mode, hard mode...
DMC2 mode, you know?
I thought it would ask.
Minto mode.
Nemoro, thanks for the 5 gifted.
Takes place last in the series.
It's last in the timeline?
No way.
Oh my god, that guy was eating that.
Oh,
that's false.
Just kidding.
No it doesn't.
Oh my god, stop spreading lies on the internet to me.
I would never know.
I'm not going in there just yet.
Wow, there's so much here.
Oh yeah baby.
Wait, am I going too far?
I'm trying to...
What the?
Oh, that's really trippy looking.
I'm trying to explore.
I don't want to go too far.
There's rorbs everywhere.
Oh my gosh.
The most elusive rorb.
The train rorb.
Wait, do I go?
Hold on.
Before we get too far.
There's some more I wanted to see on the other side.
I guess.
I thought there was another...
I can't tell if I can go in there or not.
I'm scared to try.
Over here.
Oh, there's...
Dang, I thought it was a...
Okay, I was going the right way.
The entire time.
Wait, what is in here though?
If I fall...
Worth it for the rorb.
Rich for the rorb.
I'm getting rich up in here.
Oh my god, his...
His like...
His sneakers.
Sounds like when Barbie is running.
In the Barbie movies.
And it's just such a nice little...
Such a nice sound.
Are those guys going to come alive?
No!
Time to fight, baby.
What if I just do this the whole time?
Oh my god,
this is what you guys tell me to do, right?
That's the strat?
Just...
It's loud?
Sorry, I had to turn it up because you guys said it was quiet earlier.
La, la, la, la, la...
Punch, punch... I mean...
Shoot, shoot, shoot...
Give me your rorbs, please.
I wonder how fast I can quote-unquote speedrun this.
I'm not really made out to be a speedrunner though.
Because I like to just run everywhere.
And look at things, like that bird.
The bird on the wall.
We are in like a whole city though.
Look at that thing.
Oh yeah, we get our own sexy ladies.
Oh my god, ouch, ouch.
Get out Dante, get out Dante!
Nice.
Oh, there's more.
I'm just gonna jump and shoot.
Oh no, my rorb!
Give it back!
Okay, nice.
Oh my gosh, they even had traffic lights.
This place is crazy.
Rip the rorb.
Maybe there's more over here.
I'll take the stairs this time.
Like a proper gentleman.
Okay, nevermind.
There's nothing here.
Guys, we are in Brazil.
Maybe I do need to jump over.
I need to become Spider-Man.
Oh my gosh.
You can't get me if I'm high in the air!
Look at...
The way I just...
The way I just float in the air is so fun.
Okay.
Oh, I just needed to hop over it.
Oh my god.
And then once you're down, then I get you.
Once you're down, then I get you.
Once you're down...
Oh wow, he's also flying!
Okay.
Oh my god.
And then I can switch to you.
And then I switch to you.
Wait, how do I switch?
Oh, nevermind.
That guy is not even coming towards me though.
Oh, now he is.
And then I switch to you.
Are they coming up behind me?
Did I hear that behind me?
I don't even know where I'm shooting.
I'm just shooting somebody.
I love auto-target.
Alright.
Sorry.
I'm shooting, I'm shooting.
If you shoot long enough you'll hit something.
Exactly.
Oh my god.
I'm shooting at somebody.
Where are you?
I think I killed him.
Okay.
I'm just gonna keep going.
Well, they make that kind of difficult now, don't they?
Go down.
Go down, buddy.
Or up, you know, whichever.
Oh, there's more.
They're never gonna stop.
No, please.
I mean, yes, keep paying me, but...
There he goes, off the screen.
What was over here?
Oh my gosh, I saw another roar, but...
I'm afraid to jump for it and I can't...
There's no way to change the camera.
There.
How do I get to that?
Will the water kill me?
Oh, come on.
Leave me alone.
I'm leaving.
I see.
We can all run away from our problems.
Be like Dante.
I got a yellow...
Oh.
Gold?
A gorb.
A crystal generated with the mortal's power of resurrection.
Oh, shoot.
They're not letting me leave this time, huh?
There he goes.
Off the screen.
Is this the...
Is this the same as before where I need the yorbs to...
To save?
Oh my gosh.
I'm styling in the air.
You resurrect.
It revives if you die.
I don't know where I'm shooting at, but...
It's probably somebody.
There he goes.
Off the screen.
Oh my god.
I got injured.
Wait.
Did I kill him?
Oh my god.
Please.
Go away.
Haven't I beat enough of you?
Meow, meow.
Do you get style points in this?
Or is it just because I'm not using my sword at all?
Oh, what's devil trigger in this?
Oh.
I'm just too good.
Isn't he stylish?
I think I've reached maximum.
Quite honestly.
Oh, F4.
Shut up.
R1?
No.
That's this.
This is R1.
Oh, L1.
R3?
Everybody is giving me something different.
Nobody knows.
That's okay.
I'm destroying the city's infrastructure.
Oh, a thing.
This is actually terrible, terrible.
Terrible architecture.
Oh there.
Statue of a god that is controlling time.
You can gain powers by offering the rorbs.
This is a menu.
Ten...
Thousand rorbs!
That's never been so expensive.
Five thousand rorbs.
I have nothing.
I'm poor as hell.
I'm just a poor guy.
If you spam circle, you'll just flip.
Wait, which one is circle?
X or B?
I need that.
The game is telling me.
But what about...
Wait.
I got a...
I got a blorb!
Oh, so I can jump in here.
I've been missing out this whole time.
Blorb flag...
Fragment.
I started to say flagment.
I think I'm trapped in here.
Just kidding.
I'm too good.
I'm styling.
Yeah, Mike Tyson's ass!
Thanks for the gift dude!
Okay, let's just keep going.
Flagment.
Oopsie.
It was a trap.
Oh my god.
These are the wimpiest spikes I've ever seen.
Ever in my afterlife.
I'm just gonna keep pressing B.
Oh my god!
They're hideous monkeys.
I have to also shoot though.
Don't worry.
They won't get me up here.
Okay, there look to be way more monkeys than before, but...
Are they doing anything?
Are they gonna move?
Nevermind, they're moving.
They're on the move.
How are you finding it so far?
I'm having so much fun.
L1?
Goodbye, minkies.
Minky, be gone.
Minky!
Minky, be gone!
Oh, more minky.
Oh my god, invisible minkies!
Nevermind.
Minky!
Death to the minky!
Alright, nice.
Hold on, I'm trying to get some more rorbs.
I gotta get paid here.
Oh no, that's a trick.
Trick.
That's a trick.
Okay, nevermind.
Goodbye, minkies!
Sayonara!
Come here.
There he goes, up the wall.
Stupid little minky.
They threw something at me.
Hold on, let me get paid.
Get money, get paid.
Here we go.
Filling the devil trigger gauge is a pain.
And this one?
A key!
Iron bar door.
Oh, can I make money?
Oh my god.
Nice.
Nice, nice.
I need lots of money.
When mink goes...
This one.
You have used the key.
Perfect.
Thanks.
On those wimpy, wimpy spikes.
I could've just taken those spikes down, let's be honest.
I like being outside.
It's kinda fun.
I like the outdoors atmosphere.
Makes me feel like...
You smell that smoggy, smog air.
Look at that.
That is not fresh.
That air is...
No wonder nobody lives here.
It's very contaminated.
Could've crawled into the pipe.
That's what I'm saying, right?
Oh man.
I should've stayed on the ceilings.
There we go.
Let's just leave.
Is that a...
Is this bait or...
Follow the road.
That's not me.
Madam.
Makes me wanna go touch grass.
His eyes are piercing.
Oh my god.
I love touching grass.
Who are you?
I'm Minto.
Dante doesn't talk for shit in this game?
What is it?
What is this?
Metal Gear Solid V?
Guys, we got a B!
Nothing even happened in that...
In that mission.
How many missions are in this game, by the way?
DMC director Hideki Itsuno was not involved in DMC2 until 6 months before the game was out.
They asked him to do his best to salvage the project.
Oh my god.
18 missions.
Okay.
Yeah, I heard...
I did, like, how long to beat on this game and it said 5 hours.
If you just wanna, like, play.
So give or take, like, a couple hours to that.
Mathieu?
Oh!
She just crawled out of the ground.
Paid for Boomer!
Check out 10% off gamers...
Thank you, Shaden.
Your friend is always responding to you on Twitter.
It's so funny.
Oh my god, he speaks.
Dante.
Okay.
I just forget how to say it.
Oh?
Why was there a dramatic pause?
A man?
What the hell is that?
Oh my god, that's what they're gonna do to Akiba.
No!
How's your tails?
Ma'am, I don't think you should be going out.
There's just like some...
About Papa?
Papa!
Guideposts for the Hunter, chapter 1, clause 8.
Guys, should I just always level up my gun in this game?
Should I wait for the 10,000 buckaroos?
Yes?
Okay.
Using the sword and melee for one fight, just so you have an idea.
Okay, I'll try.
I'll try.
No, I liked being outside!
Hello?
Oh, there we go.
Wish me luck on 14 ultimate.
Good luck, bro!
You got this.
I'm teeny tiny.
Oh my god, the camera changes.
Hello?
Anybody in here?
I'll go that way in a second.
There's another way.
Woah, there's so many ways.
Do you plan on doing both Dante and Lucia or just Dante?
Just Dante.
The cutscenes are different, people said.
But I can just watch them on YouTube.
Oh, I'm supposed to break all of them.
Wait, I didn't go down the holes though.
Oh shit.
Oh, it's just a bunch of little bats.
Oh no, bats!
Okay.
Oh, he's trying to open like a little... Okay.
I thought they were like all in their own hallways.
This one has...
A pickle.
What in the...
Oh yeah, baby!
Oh, just kidding.
How can I... Can I lock... I wish I could lock on but it's...
Oh, it's over.
No!
Wait!
3000!
You guys were so close.
Where did that open anyway?
I can't get a grasp of how any of these...
I can't get a grasp on how any of these rooms are supposed to look because...
I don't... I can't move the camera.
Where did... Is this where I came from?
Already on mission 2 and Dante hasn't gotten stabbed through the chest.
The sword... chest...
I can't enunciate today.
What is wrong with me?
I think it's because my eyes are like this.
My eyes are up here.
Where am I going?
This way?
My dearest Melpert, it has come to our attention that you forced a ghost maid to...
A ghost maid to complete your DMC 2 playthrough.
We are disappointed in you, Melpert.
What are you talking about?
Wait, what is...
What happened to all the things that I opened up?
Did it get sealed up?
Did I mess up?
Aw man, I think I messed up.
Hi, Melpert!
Nah, I'm Minto.
How's it, Melpert?
Good secret.
Good secret, good secret.
Oh my god, nice!
Maybe I should fall down the other one.
Wait, should I?
Gosh.
Should I fall down the other one?
It's a Vinny bit.
If I ever meet him, I'll ask him.
I'm sure Mitara would introduce us.
I just love seeing these, like...
I wish the camera angle stayed and all you saw was Dante just sometimes jumping out of the hole.
Like this.
Aw man, it was a trick.
Played DMC 2.
I'm playing DMC 2!
Oh, this is this room.
I'm playing, I'm playing DMC 2!
I hope you're happy for me!
I hope you're happy!
Don't forget to use your guns.
Oh my swords!
I gotta use the sword, huh?
I don't have the...what's it called anymore?
Wait, where the hell am I supposed to go here?
I'm playing DMC 2.
I hope you're happy for me.
Is there a map?
Look at...
Wait, he looks different here.
He's got no boobs.
This is sad.
DM...wait, here?
Oh, I found it.
Is this a puzzle?
I'm thinking of...all I can think of is Astro Bot right now.
This is technically a puzzle.
Quotes!
Ebony and Ivory is more effective than the pool noodle on your back.
Don't call her that!
She's beautiful!
None of them sound different.
Am I overthinking it?
Oh my gosh, wait, hold on.
The textures on the ceiling don't even line up.
You see that?
I see it.
Oh, go to the door and interact with it first.
Light a blue flame and then the way will be opened.
What the...
Am I a dog?
Oh, that's all I...
Oh, I was destroying...I was creating a hero on the thing.
I was like...what?
It was making those blue.
I get it.
I got it.
I can't see anything.
What could be in this room?
A door.
What's over here?
Money?
No.
What's this?
Oh.
I already beat it, but I also got confused.
Don't get confused!
Blorp!
This looks like a trap.
Are
you gonna move or do anything?
Yeah, I'll try using my sword.
Look, it's working!
Don't worry.
He's...
Oh, he has his legs.
Is he still alive or...
I think he's dead.
Oh, thanks.
He even had a health bar.
Wow.
He just took it.
What a man.
Oh my god.
I'm trying to...I'm trying to...
Nice!
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
I'm using my sword, everybody!
OK, nevermind.
I'll go back.
Nice.
So it's kind of worth falling down these.
Just because it might be a pleasant surprise.
Or a stinky surprise.
You never know, unless you try it out.
Now you can see why the game is the way that it is.
Nah.
Oh my gosh, if I had gone here first I would have locked myself out of that riveting...
Where is he?
Oh, it's a bunch of bats!
I would have locked myself out of that riveting mini-boss.
That would have been so sad.
And I open up another path.
There is nothing in here?
OK.
Run Dante, run!
I guess this way.
Wait, where is your roar?
Oh my goodness.
Ah!
I'm being surrounded.
Give me your money.
Where is the other guy?
Oh, they all have health.
I'm just stupid I think.
I think I just never noticed.
There it goes.
Give me your money.
Where is he?
Is he in there?
Are you in there?
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
What's down here?
I love the savage golems.
At least the other one is moving.
Oh my god.
I can't.
I can't with this.
Oh my god.
He like even attempted an attack before.
OK, hold on.
Turbo!
He tried.
Oh my god.
Oh, they regenerate.
Oh, interesting.
Let's kill this guy off first then.
Kill him, kill him dead.
OK.
Where is he going?
Oh my god, this is so sad.
Something hurt me, I think.
I actually can't tell.
I wasn't looking at the screen.
He starts to crawl.
For real.
That wasn't worth my time, I think.
That was...
Yeah, I felt like I was bullying those guys.
They're tanks, but...
They're just really silly.
A lot, a lot, a lot, a lot.
Oh, no, no, no.
Dante, Dante, turn around.
There you go.
Is this how meet and greets will be like from now on?
What?
What do you mean by that?
We run to the door.
Oh!
A time.
How much roar do I have?
3000.
The path is long.
The road is tough.
Where were you?
I meant to make Savage Golem cry.
Oh my god.
The door tried to get me.
Hey, guys.
Oh my gosh.
That was close.
That was also close.
I'm not hitting anything.
Get out, Dante!
You're crazy!
You're maniacs!
Dante, please shoot any of them.
Please.
Dante, Dante, shoot.
Like, aim Dante!
Aim Dante!
Oh my god, there's more of them.
Oh, no, these are the pyromancers.
They seem...
I can't tell if they're...
Did that reach me or...
I can't tell.
There he goes.
Okay, there he goes.
See you later!
We did it.
Oh, I should have Devil Triggered.
I keep forgetting that this is...
Well, now I can.
Easy.
No way!
I got a girl!
Amazing.
Did I lose all... What is this?
It refilled my Devil Trigger?
Oh my god.
Let's go.
Thanks for the Super Chat!
Eh, start blasting.
Capcom greenlit the sequel before the first game came out.
Aerial heart.
A magic stone with the heart of a flying demon bird.
Does that mean I can fly now?
And Devil Trigger.
That's why they let me replenish.
Take that.
Get those.
Wait, where are they?
Oh, they're higher up?
Am I stupid?
Grab the orbs.
My depth perception.
Where are they?
Grab the orbs.
Grab the orb!
Where is it?
OK, I got it.
Alright, we're gonna replenish...
and then we'll just fly up.
Easy.
Got it.
Oh my god, mission clear!
Rank C.
For C, I did it.
Mickey.
Alright baby.
Nice.
Next mission.
C for gun.
Oh my god.
The key to the next journey begins and ends with death.
Wait, what happened to my Devil Trigger?
It completely depleted.
What?
No!
That's unfair.
It got stolen from me.
Looks like we're in London.
Stanky.
London's got orbs.
What's going on?
Where is the goatling?
Oh shit.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Roll!
Dante, roll!
Roll Dante!
Keep going!
Dante!
We're not there yet!
My Devil Trigger is all gone!
Otherwise I would have...
Now I'm close enough?
Oh my god.
He's right there!
Oh there we go, there we go, there we go.
I
don't want him to do anymore of the...
There we go, there we go.
Nice, nice, nice.
No, no, no.
Focus on him, focus on him, focus on him.
Focus on him, focus on him.
Such engaging gameplay, yeah?
You guys are entertained or you're not entertained?
Oh my god, it's this stuff again.
Can you like leave me alone?
You, right there.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my god.
Stop summoning guys, please.
I'm stuck in here.
I like how he stopped drops and rolls, for real.
Please, calling.
Calling, take my hits.
Eat my bullets.
Please.
You do be spamming the flame.
Oh my god.
He's dead!
Give me your money.
Money.
They're like, hey, you wanna spend those buckaroos?
No, I'm saving up for the big boys.
Where'd the rest of the money go?
I saw it, I saw it on the street lamps.
Game, you didn't rob me, did you now?
This place is too clean to be London.
Oh, here we go, here we go.
Every orb.
What about on the other sides?
We have that door there.
Were there any other sides?
I don't think this looks very clean.
I don't know what you're used to, but I don't think this looks very...
Well, I guess there's not, like, litter everywhere.
What the?
Cool.
Leave me alone!
Go into the air.
There he goes, flying upwards.
There he goes.
There he goes, into the air.
Off to heaven.
Give me my money.
There he goes.
Oh my god, my ROARBS!
You made me miss them!
How do I use the stinger again?
I don't remember.
You thought I wouldn't check for a ROARB, huh?
What the?
That was the final boss?
Was it really?
I need more
ROARBS.
I'm a poor, poor guy.
I'm poor.
I need ROARBS.
Thank you very much.
I'm poor for ROARBS.
It's okay, he'll never touch me.
He's going to space.
What's that?
What's that, like...
You know the song.
Space song.
And this is why we explore.
For the BLORBS.
Double BLORB?
Oh no, I got a single BLORB.
Let's go.
Use sword for more ROARBS.
Really?
It'll give me more?
Okay.
Ducktales moon theme.
Ducktales.
I'm still too poor.
I'm poor.
Did the Ducktales game ever, like...
What?
That
was supposed to be mine!
But didn't it, like...
It, like, was stuck on a certain... like on Xbox or something and then...
Oh.
That's a bigger monkey.
I'm shooting him!
Oh my gosh.
Hey, don't come towards me.
Jump, jump, jump!
Oh, you can just hold the button and DT?
Oh no way.
Okay, good to know.
I'm shooting, I'm shooting, I'm shooting, I'm shooting, I'm shooting, I'm shooting.
I don't know where I am.
I'm stuck in the void.
Oh my god.
There's other monkeys too.
Here, I'm gonna try.
Oh my gosh.
No, no, no, no.
Focus on that.
Focus on him.
Oh, there's just random monkeys everywhere.
Oh my god.
He's almost dead.
Random monkeys, random monkeys.
Oh shoot.
Where am I?
Oh, I'm close, I'm close.
We're killing him, we're killing him.
Where is he going?
Where the hell is he going?
Oh, he's coming towards me.
Is he summoning more?
Ouch.
Just shoot the monkeys.
I hate that the hand is grabbing at me at the same time.
It's so messed up.
What am I shooting at?
What am I even... I'm not even getting him.
What am I doing?
And he's dead.
Easy.
The doors literally... I'm catching strays from the door.
Huge gate.
Oh, a key to unlock a huge gate blocking a passage from the station to the harbor.
And then there were grorbs in the corner.
Wait, those are still there, right?
Thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you.
Yummy.
Monkey down.
I guess I don't really need it, but...
Oh, it gives me grorbs.
Five thousand grorbs.
So this one?
I would like one ticket to the east side, please.
What gate?
What is this to?
This one?
Oh, a key.
Oh my god!
We got it back!
Let's go to the other big gate.
Alright, we are half way to upgrade our guns.
What the hell is this?
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
There's things every...
God, I hate the ones that throw the stuff.
Gosh, at this rate I'm never gonna get...
I'm never gonna get these grorbs.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
I'm gonna get the grorbs that people are dropping right now.
Oh, this guy is like right in front of me.
Please die!
You guys suck.
Grorb!
The wheelskeletons, yeah, they suck so much.
So leave me alone!
There he goes.
I'm gonna collect my money and you're gonna go to space.
And that's just how this works out.
And I get the other grorb.
Perfect.
I hate wheelskeletons.
I hate those guys.
Oh, there's more of them.
Be-be-be-be-be-be-be-be-be-be-be-be-be-be-be-be-be-be-be-be-be-be-be-be-be-be-be-be-be-be-be-be...
Who's behind me?
Oh my god!
More birdies?
They're not doing much.
OK.
Oh my god, they're never... Never ending!
I don't mind these guys so much.
There he goes.
To become one with the birds.
It's like my birdie waifu is up there.
Now we just shoot the... The feather is dropping.
It's so sad.
Wait, isn't this the bad one?
There's never such thing...
As the bad.
Can I just leave?
Is this not the door?
Oh my god.
Which one is the door?
I assume I mentioned it earlier, OG DuckTales and DuckTales Remastered are both on Steam.
Oh, really?
So it did get released.
It got... Ouch!
Oh my god.
DT?
Yeah, you're right.
You're right.
Who else is... Oh my god.
Where's the door that I need to go to?
I just got the key!
Look at their flopping bodies.
This is so sad.
Ouchie ouch.
Why did I even try?
What is this?
This is sad!
I'm gonna leave.
I showed you in the cutscene.
I didn't see it!
Where was it?
I didn't see it.
Oh my god.
I'm going back.
Wait, what?
Next to the boss door?
Oh my god, this one?
Oh, I thought that was inside the room.
Wait, no.
This one.
I'm styling.
I missed it.
Yeah, see?
This is what I came through.
The one with the light.
There was one with the light.
Fancy angel doors.
Oh my god.
It's okay, we were grinding.
For lots of money.
Yeah, we farmed the rorbs.
We are so close now, actually.
Actually.
She has many arms, but only one heart.
As she waits for the hunter deep in the water.
I don't know what that means, but...
I wanna meet her.
Okay.
Please.
Don't do it.
Let's... Okay.
Alright.
Okay.
No.
This way.
Oh my god.
Rorbs!
Yo, that was incredible.
That felt so good.
That was the best feeling thing that we've experienced so far.
Come on monkeys.
There he goes.
Up to the sky, little monkey.
Oh my goodness.
Where did you come from?
Rorb!
Excuse me.
Wait, how do I get that?
Oh yeah!
I think I won.
God.
So far, my honest opinion.
I understand what people complain about.
But, I'm still having a good time.
Nevermind.
This game sucks.
Far, far away.
The Rorb world.
Oh, more of them?
Are the others gonna notice?
That their friend is going into space?
Oh my goodness.
They're just dropping like flies here.
Wait, how do I stinger again?
Don't worry.
Come on!
The stinger is so depressing.
I don't even hit them.
Hold on.
Let me get my money.
Alright.
Knock it off, buddy.
The limp stinger.
Let me get my money.
Oh, lots of money.
Oh my god.
These guys just don't stop coming.
There he goes.
Oh, that guy is dead too.
So, is there a reason why Dante doesn't talk a lot?
Or is it just...
Were they just like, this guy is suddenly our silent protagonist?
He forgot how to speak?
Dante!
It's just a pile of wood.
He talks a lot in 3 and later games.
Do we get any... Where is his witty one-liners, you know?
Wow.
Holy moly.
Guys, we are so close.
We are actually so close.
Oh my god.
This is it.
Don't fall off, Dante.
Please.
Oh my god.
We are gonna get the 10,000.
Please.
So close.
The sound of gunshots caused some short-term hearing loss.
I believe that.
I really like the atmosphere though.
I'll give them that.
I really like the...
The locations and stuff.
It's fun.
His outfit is pink too.
Yeah, exactly.
Oh, okay.
Nevermind.
Set design is cool.
Yeah.
Very cool.
Grab those.
No.
I said those.
There we go.
Oh my gosh.
Lighthouse.
What is this?
How was it done?
Hold on.
There is more for me to see.
One second.
The red cotton did it.
I can hear.
Oh.
Wait.
Can I... Maybe I jump over?
No?
How
do I get over there though?
Maybe when I come back?
Let's see.
You need DT?
No way.
Do you think it's worth it?
Oh my god.
I messed it up, I think.
I think I need to go from this side.
Okay, hold on.
Why is there an invisible wall?
Oh my god.
Nevermind.
I give up.
It's so messed up.
What is this thing though?
Oh, I did it.
Is this faster I wonder?
Let's try.
Okay, okay, okay.
Stop!
I don't need to see the cutscene!
I need to run!
Oh my god.
Dante.
We are not gonna make it.
Dante, you can crawl through there.
I need DT sprint.
Yeah, but I already wasted it earlier so I don't wanna waste it now.
Okay, I give up.
I give up.
Okay, anyway.
It's just these guys.
I guess we'll get more DT here.
Just gonna keep going and...
Keep going.
There he goes up into space.
This guy over here is lazy.
Literal lazy bones not doing anything.
He's like, I just wanna fly man.
I don't wanna do anything.
Just send me to space already.
Oh, I'm getting two for the price of one!
I might be so good at this game I think.
I might be so good at this game.
She's a pro.
That's what we call speedrun strategies.
What is this?
This is gonna happen every time?
Oh wait, now we have the power of...
What?
What do we have?
Quick heart.
A magic stone with the heart of a running demon beast.
That's what it wants me to do.
I got it.
Wait, hello?
Talk to this.
300?
Guys were so close.
Now you can run to the door.
Yeah, exactly.
Is anyone gonna come up here?
Probably not, right?
Wait,
I'm not hitting him.
Come on, aim Dante!
Dante, he's right there.
Where are the other guys?
Where did their money go?
Oh, I saw it.
Where are you?
Come here.
Please play DMC2!
It's the best game!
Please, please, please!
Nice.
Stop, please!
Stop!
Am I really fast now?
I don't feel so fast.
I feel average.
Oh my God!
Did you equip the stone?
There is a stone I have to equip?
Well, I didn't know that.
Oh wait, quick cart.
I think I auto equipped.
Yeah, I think so too.
Because it was there.
Hold on.
I'm gonna fight more bozos in here.
I'm gonna just fight more bozos in here.
Once our devil tricker is higher.
Honestly, I feel like we could farm these guys for like a minute.
And get enough money to upgrade the guns.
I'm not gonna lie.
I feel like maybe...It's
less than 200, but we are so close.
See?
It might take a second, but...
Oh my God, we are so close.
We are so close!
I'm just 101 dalmatians left!
Call me Cruella de Vil!
I'm hungry for money and puppies!
Isn't there a rorb in the room?
Is there?
No!
You can almost taste the upgrade.
I know!
Sweet!
Sweet enemies!
Come here!
Oh, I was angled to get them both at the same time.
I lost the angle.
Dante is clocked into a 9 to 5.
What are you talking about?
I'm locked in now.
Don't even think about using turbo.
I'm using turbo!
I trained in Metal Gear for this moment.
50!
51 actually.
Baby, it feels so good!
Oh my God, we made it.
We made it!
Alright.
I wish I could stop this from happening.
The cutscene, I mean.
Run!
Oh my God.
Yes!
More money.
Alright!
We did it, baby!
Oh, hello?
I don't know how to use stairs anymore.
That's it?
Alright.
I like it though.
Okay.
Let's go inside!
Clutch roll.
I know!
Is that the madam with many legs?
Oh my gosh.
Is she healing?
Okay, hold on.
That's not good.
Guys, I think I'm an idiot.
Guys, I was looking at my own health.
I keep rolling.
I just roll.
Hello?
Am I even hitting her?
Oh, I am.
Okay, I see.
I see.
Oh my gosh.
I killed a thing.
Oh no, a new one forms though.
Oh, I see.
I see.
What the hell?
Stop just... Hold on.
I guess I'll get my...
My what's it called?
Tentacles do not count on damage.
Yeah, I noticed that.
We did such good damage to her before.
There we go.
Ouch.
Ouchy ouch.
No, get her!
At least we got a little bit in.
Ouch.
Warp?
Oh my god, please.
Don't take it up.
I like getting the corner guy.
Like this one.
But then I only have to deal with one guy rather than so many guys.
Oh, never mind.
He's back.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
Oh, I'm trapped.
Never mind.
I don't like being in the corner.
Oh, I thought I was in the air.
This damn camera angle, I swear.
There we go.
No, get her!
Get her!
Get...
I feel like I'm not gonna win this one.
Oh my gosh.
I feel like I'm gonna have to do this one again.
No.
Oh my god, and I even jumped and I didn't even know anything.
I went to the main bar of health.
Guys, this is so bad.
I think you can manually change targets.
I have not figured out a way if you can.
Oh my gosh, please.
Oh my gosh.
And then you can't see where the tentacle is when you're up in the air.
This sucks.
This fight actually sucks so much.
L3?
No.
Wait.
I'm pressing L3.
It's not working.
Just figured what out now.
What?
The thing that someone told me and that doesn't work?
That thing?
The boss is defeated by sword?
Are you sure?
Oh, I tried sword and it just pushed me out.
And I died.
Oh, I'm not dead!
Please die, tentacle!
Oh my gosh, every time I think it's gonna die.
And it deals big ol' damage.
Sucks.
Please.
There we go.
Okay.
No!
Go for her!
I can't even get to her when I do the sword though.
I can't even get to her when I do the sword.
Oh my gosh, please.
I can't see where I am.
She became a bubble.
Ouch, ouch.
Please.
Is there a grorb anywhere?
Oh my gosh.
No, please don't take it out.
Oh my gosh, please, please, please.
Don't stop jumping Dante!
What the?
Oh my gosh, a warb.
Elusive warb.
Guys, I feel like I'm gonna die though.
For real.
I'll try with the sword.
See, every time I try with the sword I literally get hit.
Every time!
I try with the sword, he takes me down.
Every time.
I know the tentacles respawn.
I'm not dumb.
Why do you think I've been fighting the same tentacle over and over again?
Oh my gosh.
Oh shit.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my god, this is so...
At least we're farming DT now.
Farm the DT.
Oh my gosh.
That was close.
I thought this was supposed to be a sexy lady.
I mean, she is kind of sexy, but like...
Okay.
Alright.
Slowly but surely, guys.
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
Back to our weekly scheduled programming while I farm more DT.
I don't even know where the hell I am.
I'm in the sky.
Okay.
Not enough.
Let's get some more.
Get some more.
Miss some more.
That was AFK.
Did I miss anything?
What?
You don't love this riveting fight?
What are you talking about?
This is the fight!
No!
I can actually direct onto his sword?
Really?
I think I'm just gonna keep going with what I'm doing though.
It's slow, but it's steady.
It's doing the job.
Sorry.
I'm just gonna keep going with what I'm doing.
It's working out, you know?
Don't listen to backseaters.
Okay.
I'm doing what I'm doing, you know?
We're just getting it done eventually.
Eventually.
She'll die eventually.
I'm surprised.
I'm surprised I'm good though.
I just keep doing what I'm doing and then...
Get back.
Get close to her.
Okay, nevermind.
Are you sure?
I'm not a speedrunner.
My methods, if they work for me, they work for me, you know?
I don't have to listen to anybody else's rules.
I follow my own path.
That was so close.
We're so close though, guys.
That was close.
Okay.
We're farming roars.
We're farming ghouls.
Well, I wish I could change the...
I wish I could change what I was locked onto.
I'm trying to shoot you, lady.
Guys, I'm just jumping in this corner.
I guess I'll just keep going at whatever this is.
R1 then L3?
Why is it so complicated?
R1 then L3.
Oh my god, it worked.
But I have to hold it!
I have to hold it for it to work!
What the hell?
This is so complicated!
What is it attacking?
I can't really tell.
How is it attacking me?
R1 then L3.
I'll do that in a second.
Okay, R1.
We did it.
Everybody...
Can I undo my DT now so that I can keep my...
I lost.
Well, no, actually I didn't have that much.
Oh my gosh, finally.
What the...
Where is it?
Please!
Where was it?
It lasted for 2 seconds!
That's so messed up!
Shotgun!
I think I'll just stay with Ebony and Ivory though.
There we go, I'm leaving town.
So did you have fun?
Nah.
Yeah.
What?
That was so...
We didn't even see him get to go over the ramp.
He just was driving.
That was certainly one of the fights of all time.
Close to your eyes, but far off in your mind, the hunter must learn the value of options.
What are you trying to say?
Also, good thing that we upgraded, right?
30...
30,000!
How do I use the shotgun?
Do I have to equip it?
Oh my god.
LT?
Wait, no, that's...
Devil Trigger.
Oh, there we go.
Sorry, OK.
OK.
Sorry, I was thinking L1.
My bad.
Oh my god, I sounded... Oh my god!
Oh my god.
Freaky!
Freaky and jerky!
Oh, Jerry, sorry.
Freaky and Jerry!
Oh, freaky!
Jerry's gonna die first, maybe.
The true freaks never die!
True freaks never die!
Wait, am I gonna kill Jerry?
Oh yeah, yeah, there he goes.
But what was about the sword?
I thought the sword was not the thing that you play in this game.
Fine.
Oh, shoot.
My bad, I accidentally Devil Triggered.
Sniper wolf.
Wolves.
The true DMC2 experience is just shoot everything.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Am I gonna have to go fight that?
I just fought a lady.
Now I'm having to fight a skele-man.
What a... Give me a break, game.
Those look like normal wolves, Dante.
No, they were Freaky and Jerry.
Forget Tom and Jerry.
All my homies love Freaky and Jerry.
Oh my gosh, we made it out of the...
We're in the big city!
The big apple, baby!
Oh my god.
Blood for the blood goat.
What if I stayed inside?
Just die already, please.
Oh my god, there's even more?
Just die already?
Thank you.
And thank you.
Where are you actually?
I can't even shoot you.
More blood goats.
There he goes.
You threw off my groove!
No!
I had such a good thing going.
Kind of.
A good thing asterisk, maybe.
Oh my god.
I'm getting my ass...feet.
I did it.
No, I said the correct thing this time.
Ah, the silence.
The silence of the city.
Let's go get our money.
Excuse me.
That's mine.
Dante doesn't know how to use his hands as usual.
Oh, his hands are full.
Never mind.
He's got the guns.
You know what?
I'll give him a pass this time.
Okay.
What is this music?
Oh my gosh, this looks like where Solidus died.
The time.
The time god.
Spooky city music, yeah.
Spoilers!
Are you...a...
Okay, hold on.
Before we go in there, because I know that's where it wants me to go.
Are you a mint phantom phantom if you don't actually know...
Metal gear facts?
Is there anything over here?
Am I crazy?
No?
Okay, just kidding.
If you hold R1 with a shotgun equipped, for some reason he will have the shotgun in one hand and a handgun in the other.
Huh?
Oh, you're right.
But he just only uses the...
He just only uses the shotgun.
Alright, into the parking garage.
Never
mind.
We went through the parking garage.
That area would have sucked anyway.
I'm actually kind of happy that we don't have to go through it.
I am going through it.
Just in other ways.
I understand that I'm wanting to make the guns better, but do they have to make the swords suck?
What the hell?
Oh my god!
Now you're just a normal ass dude!
What is this?
You can't just become a normal enemy!
What does the green health... Wait, so it goes from green to...
I'm guessing green to yellow to red?
Oh yeah, there it is.
Green to yellow to red.
It's okay.
He's almost... Oh, to orange!
That's what happens when you use your sword, everybody.
Wait, I'm sorry.
Where...
Oh, I thought he was like gonna... Oh my goodness.
I thought he was gonna...
I'm gonna handle this now, everybody.
We're just gonna handle this now.
In our own way, okay?
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
These guys are just standing around.
Quit monkeying around, guys!
Little monkeys!
He didn't give us big money, did he?
No.
Big monkey, little money.
So sad.
I'm not gonna lie, when fighting that monkey, the big one, my eyes started to glaze over.
Can I understand why DMC fans tell people to skip 2?
Yeah...
It's only been 2 hours, though.
I still intend on beating it.
However long it takes, you know, whatever.
Oh, invisible wall.
That's exciting.
They hate exploration.
Over here?
They hate exploration!
About 5 hours.
That's what I said on how long to beat, but I always add a couple more for me.
Like 2 or 3 more.
This is where I came through.
So, monkey.
Or is it...
Hello?
I'm estimating 8 hours.
Yeah, that's about what I was thinking too.
Hello?
Over the truck?
Oh, okay.
I thought I couldn't go that way because it was preventing me.
No!
Ah, gosh.
The camera angles make me all tripped up.
Oh, okay.
Infested tank!
Can I just stand on top of it?
What else is shooting at me?
No way.
Okay.
This is actually working.
Guys?
There appears to be a third tank.
Oh, my gosh.
What if I stand back here?
Wait, don't shoot down, Dante.
You have a literal thing...
You have a literal thing that is telling you where to shoot.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm gonna need more money.
I'm so used to saying more money in these games.
I'm gonna need more health in this.
You know what?
I'll DT.
It'll heal me, at least.
A little bit.
Where's the other one?
There it is.
Can the other one hit me from here is the question.
Can the
other one hit me from here is the big question.
You DT when low health mode?
You go sicko, really?
Wow, guys.
This is just doing really awesome stuff.
Mega DT.
Good to know.
It's like trying to hit me.
So glad to see the stinker playing the best DLC game.
Let's go get the other one.
Wherever it is.
Try shotgun?
Oh, yeah.
I'll try.
That's what I was about to do.
I was about to jump.
I think the others are better for this.
I'm trapped.
There we go.
DT?
So true.
Oh wait!
Ouch!
No!
I was getting hurt at the same time!
When can't I ever get more grorbs?
Maybe I must search.
Had a dream last night.
I attended an official mint cafe.
Oh my gosh.
I'd go crazy if that ever happened.
I know that if I raise my style meter, I get more grorbs, but I don't really care.
I'll be honest.
I can't.
Come on.
Suck it in, Dante.
Skinny legend.
Where am I?
Is this where I'm supposed to go?
Not up the ramp?
What do I get?
A magic stone with the heart of a vigorous battle god.
An offense heart?
What does that mean?
I was hoping for a grorb.
I think it automatically...hold on...equips, right?
Yeah!
Automatically equipped.
Nice.
More damage.
Let's go.
I'm gonna save.
I don't know if this will do anything, but just because I'm so low on health...
I think that worked.
Nice.
Cool, we found that.
Is there anything on the other side?
I'm just exploring, trying to find something to heal me.
Maybe up here.
Up here.
Oh my
God, where am I?
Where is the copter?
Oh there it is.
Oh my God.
Am I doing damage?
Yes!
Where did it leave me at?
Do I have to do all that again?
No way.
No way!
It's just such a...
They weren't difficult, it's just such a time consuming thing.
Oh come on.
They just eat.
But I got the other thing for my DT, which is nice.
That's DMC2.
What?
Everything is so tanky in this game.
I don't understand.
They're not very difficult, it's just all of it...
Like actual... Oh my God.
Okay, nevermind.
Like actual literal tanks.
Actually I wonder if me being on the ground is better for this one.
Why you can't... It's just shooting into the air.
Oh, there it goes.
Finally it grew a brain.
What the... What is this?
I feel so slow for some reason.
Aren't you having fun?
I'm just gonna do this.
Oh, nevermind.
This guy is actually fast.
Sometimes they take big hit and sometimes little hit.
I don't understand why.
Sometimes big hit, sometimes teeny tiny hit.
I think it's like where I'm shooting at.
If you hit the eye you do more damage.
Oh my God, he's actually doing something else.
Oh my God, they are actual enemies in the game.
This is incredible.
Oh my God.
Oh, now you wanna do something.
Now you wanna hit me?
What is this?
Makes no sense.
Oh my God.
What is this?
Samir is DT running out faster.
It feels that way, right?
Like I feel like I had a full thing...
And I got to use it for like 2 seconds.
Yeah, Dante definitely needs some snarky one liners.
Bun uses the DT faster.
No way, is that true?
Okay,
so the offense heart did stay.
That's so strange.
Automaton tank.
Tank.
It's all the way up here.
Rorb and blorb.
Wait,
now I'm gonna have to... Hold on.
Maybe I can avoid the...
Hold on.
We got this.
Now I can go back for this.
There we go.
We're good.
Exit.
No, no, no.
There we go.
I'm cartwheeling.
I'm styling.
Okay.
More progress.
So no jump on the helicopter.
I understand now.
Oh.
Anything here?
Nope.
This is where we were before.
Okay, just kidding.
Let me out.
Not into the fire, because I feel like this is the type of game that would hurt you with the fire.
Run in this part.
No, it was surrounded by fire.
I don't think you can run.
Run.
I'm guessing... Okay.
There we go.
It just kind of comes here and twitches a little and we don't say anything.
Like we're just...
It just kind of is like...
It doesn't really do anything.
Oh, wait.
I
wonder if this is better.
I don't know where I went, but...
If
I go back outside...
I can't go out!
Who designed this building?
Who designed this?
This makes no sense.
Oh, there's a door there.
Sorry, it was me.
Gosh, wisps.
Wait, I can't do the famous Dante jump from...
No!
I don't know... The music is stressing me out.
I feel like I should be doing something way more awesome than...
What's going on?
Oh, shoot.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I can't see!
What?
Where am I supposed to go from?
Okay.
Thanks for... He's like patiently waiting for me, which is really nice.
He's not really bothering me.
What?
I'm trying to run!
Oh, oh, I need to...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that was close.
Is it like a fire?
The building's on fire?
Dante!
Oh my gosh, Dante.
Dante, Dante.
Oh, shit, shit, shit, shit.
No!
I guess they're like, if you're not good at the wall...
The wall jumps, you'll get good, I guess.
Oh my god, my depth perception, though.
Please.
Ouch!
I made it!
That's all I gotta do?
Oh my god.
That's not how missiles should be working!
Oh my gosh.
Ouch!
Hello?
These are demon missiles, so...
Oh my gosh.
So true.
Hello?
Maybe I don't wanna stand there.
Why is this so familiar?
Oh my gosh.
Oh god.
Okay, I do have to actually shoot them.
Or they won't stop.
Good to know.
Shooting you from all the way over here.
You're shooting me.
I'm shooting you.
We're shooting each other.
You're shooting me.
That's just how these things work.
Oh, I ran right into it.
I was trying to get in between it.
I can't tell if I'm hitting anything.
Oh, I am now.
Okay, good.
Okay, you're shooting me, I'm shooting you.
That's just how these games are.
Oh my god!
I'm shooting you.
Oh my gosh.
You're shooting me.
Wait, why is he getting so shaky like that?
What's happening?
Oh, he's almost dead.
Just a little bit more.
I think... Oh my gosh.
Yeah, there we go.
Okay.
We did it.
Everything is barred.
Gosh.
What?!
Where is he?
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, you get new health, but I have to stay in my old same health.
What kind of madness is this, huh?
Phase 5!
Don't say that.
I don't even know if you're joking or not.
I don't even know where the heck this thing is.
Oh, it's telling me to go over there?
And go up?
What if I did that after I killed the stupid helicopter that is trying to murder me?
Oh.
I should dodge roll for those, shouldn't I?
What the?
Wait, where am I going?
Game?
Upwards?
Game, I can't see anything anymore.
Why are there other enemies?
Leave me alone!
Don't I have enough to deal with?
Oh my gosh, these assholes.
Leave me alone!
The poo-poo... The poo-poos.
Okay, there we go.
Upwards... Oh shoot!
That's what I'm gonna do, baby.
To these damn poo-poos.
Stupid ass birds, I hate birds.
Stupid birds!
Actually, that's a lie, I really love birds.
I like the ones that talk.
It's a little disturbing, but like...
It's pretty fun, I think.
Favorite bird?
I don't think I really have a favorite.
Gosh, why is this mission the longest mission ever in the world?
And there's also...
Nice.
Oh my gosh, I got full health.
Okay, I missed every single...
At least I got the gorb!
Oh my gosh, we're still going.
Okay.
Where is the helicopter coming back?
Where do I go from here?
You show me that area, I can't see shit.
Do I go up here?
I guess?
I'm so lost.
Is this where I'm supposed to be climbing?
Is this correct?
Oh my god.
Dante, you are aiming.
You are literally aiming.
Why don't you not shoot where you aim at?
There we go.
My goodness.
The rorbs show the way?
Okay.
I'm following the rorbs!
Oh, please!
What is this?
Getting over it?
No, I can't do this!
Oh my god.
This might actually tilt me enough.
Okay.
Alright.
Equip DT and fly.
Oh, I don't have enough DT.
I guess we'll try.
How much of this will I have to redo if I die?
Okay, screw it.
Fly!
It's the slowest ever.
It doesn't go down so fast.
Because I'm not using my guns.
Oh my god!
You guys saved me!
Thank you!
Okay.
I'm just gonna keep shooting.
I don't know where it is, but I'm apparently getting it.
What is happening?
I'm just gonna keep shooting.
How did I get all the way over there?
Sorry, I'm not paying attention at all.
I'm just gonna keep shooting.
I'm just gonna keep shooting?
Just gonna keep shooting?
Oh my god.
Ouchie, ouch.
That's a big numbers on me.
Just gonna keep shooting?
This is like the actually...
Oh my gosh.
Holy moly.
This feels like actually the longest chapter...
Ever.
I feel like I've been on this mission for 15 years.
If this chapter were a human, this chapter would be able to legally drink.
I think.
He just spawned in.
Where did he go?
Just gonna keep shooting?
He's like above me.
Like the shadow just spawns in sometimes.
Just gonna keep shooting?
Oh shoot.
Oh my gosh.
He's actually doing something.
I didn't know I could fall off.
That's insane.
Oh my gosh.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Well, that requires some DT.
Oh, it's dead!
All of that climbing Dante, just for you to jump...
I'm cool.
My god.
Oh, no, I already did it.
Here we go.
37 minutes for that one mission.
Holy hell!
Good lord.
I think that's what I was just on was Tower of Misery.
For real.
Is there any items we should buy?
Maybe we should buy some devil stars.
Do they work the same as in before?
Upgrade sword?
No, I won't be using it.
Oh, it's the plorb, right?
The plorb is what we gotta get, right?
Plorbs and plorbs, baby.
Upgrade pistol?
You saw how much it was?
It's 30,000.
I'm actually gonna do two plorbs.
Nevermind.
Oh, it went up in price.
You absolutely asshole.
I need more money to get the...
Where am I actually?
This is where the parking garage is.
That's what I thought.
I'm here again because...
What?
I'm here again, why?
Real cutscene.
Oh
my god, the pregnant building!
Already?
Warplation, true.
Oh my god!
I'm dead.
My controller was rumbling so much, it felt nice.
I was giving my thigh a massage.
So loud, oh my gosh.
Why didn't you say anything, Dante?
Oh, ouch.
Nef Asteris.
Oh, what the?
It looked like it was up in the sky.
Oh my god, I'm gonna die here.
Now he's eating the ground?
What am I shooting at?
Oh, little bats?
Actual bats.
Why?
Bats all over the place?
Okay.
Thanks for that, alright.
What is he doing?
What am I doing?
What's happening?
What's going on?
Okay.
Just keep doing that, man.
It actually got me that one time.
Oh, I see, I see.
There's a big one.
Oh, ouch, ouch.
Okay.
Mini Man!
Oh my god.
Ouch, ouch.
How am I supposed to avoid that?
Oh gosh.
Okay.
I don't understand these lines at all.
Also, I'm hearing, like, something dying.
No!
Not these again.
No way.
I'm hearing, like, the noises coming from the left side of my...
I'm so confused.
How have I lost so much health?
Oh gosh.
Oh no, it's still, you know what, it's fine.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
I don't
understand this part.
I'm just gonna go behind them and shoot.
It gets so close to me.
Oh my god!
Alright, nevermind.
I'm not worried.
Oh, shoot.
Oh my god.
I think I can just dodge everything though.
I wish I could get more DT, please.
Just a little bit.
This is so...
This is just so...
I'm gonna get a little bit more before I DT.
You know what?
Actually, this works.
No!
Oh, okay.
I was gonna...
No!
No, please!
God, no!
Oh, that's it.
Dante had nothing to say about it.
Dante is so quiet!
Five minutes.
Oh, it feels so good.
Oh!
I forgot to save.
You know what?
Maybe it's fine.
A meeting of power shall end in conflict.
Wait, so they had that whole big cutscene just for that guy and all he does is go...
That's all he did!
He did nothing!
Oh my god!
He threw out some bats and puked up some orbs and that was it?
That was all he did?
TMC2 Dante vs.
MGSV Snake.
Both are oiled up butt naked.
Who's winning the quiet game?
I think I've actually only heard Dante speak one time, so right now he's...
He's winning.
I haven't even heard him grunt.
I've only...
I think Dante's winning so far.
Where's the sexy lady at?
Where'd she go?
Yeah, Snake at least speaks in the tapes.
Barely.
I love all of Dante's famous lines in this.
Like...
And...
So true!
Okay, should I power up?
I'm gonna maybe save up for handgun level.
Or do I want to get another porb?
Or get a porb?
No, I'll get a porb.
I'm gonna get a porb and then we'll start saving up.
Mission start.
Okay, if he speaks in this cutscene...
I'll eat my foot.
Metal... Mother Base?
He did not speak in that cutscene.
In fact, we didn't even see him.
Oh, okay.
Guys, my foot is saved today.
What the hell?
What is this decor?
Okay.
Foot secured.
Why are we here?
Oh.
Just to suffer, but also...
Why are we at this location?
Oh, sorry.
I wasn't paying attention.
Destroyed demon gear.
There's one... There's a couple, I hear them.
Oh, hello.
Oh my gosh.
All I'm doing is shooting.
Oh!
He got ahead of me, actually.
Probably because I'm not moving around or doing anything.
I'm just standing there.
I'm just standing there blasting.
I like how he spins when he is...
getting back up though.
It's fun.
Oh, that guy was just...
That guy was also just standing there.
He's my kindred spirit.
Oh my gosh, are they ever gonna end?
Say please.
Please!
What am I saying please for?
Oh my gosh, I feel like any second now...
Oh.
Any second now we're gonna see some guy...
Who's...
Sneaking, suiting it up.
Is this a cutscene?
Yes.
No more, please!
Please!
Leave me alone!
Does this do anything?
No.
Guys, I don't even have anything to really commentate.
Derpy Markiplier...
Crack eyes.
What's that mean?
I'm not Markiplier.
If I was, my brother would be a furry.
I don't even have a brother.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Hello?
I'm Markiplier.
Oh gosh!
Wait, people joked about me falling asleep in this game.
I didn't think it would be right.
What the hell is this?
Oh, he has this thing.
Alright.
Let's go upwards?
Upwards.
Wait, I can't see.
Okay, nevermind, we go downwards.
Hello, Mintiplier.
Wasn't it up though?
Down then up.
Oh, I thought it was...
The golem guy.
Oh my god!
I guess if he explodes, we don't get any money.
That's kind of lame.
But it blows up the other guys, so that's kind of nice.
All the way down.
Are you guys looking forward to the weekend?
Got any weekend plans?
Oh my god.
Why did that guy jump at me but explode at the same time?
A robotics competition?
That sounds so awesome.
I guess my DT is full.
Um...
We got it!
And we get a new thing!
The same cutscene every time.
I'm so sad Dante doesn't talk!
Speak to us Dante!
A magic stone with a fierce flame demon.
Okay.
That made my tummy drop.
Oh, so I can either do flame or lightning.
Which one is better?
He doesn't have voice chat.
MC2 sleep ASMR when you just hear the...
Of the gun.
And you're just like...
Music to my ears.
Oh, I can save here.
I don't know if it makes a difference, but...
Let's at least try.
Oh gosh, okay.
It only affects sword attacks.
Wait, what?
Oh, the flame?
Oh, nevermind then.
This one.
There we go.
Get some caffeine.
I'm right after... Actually...
Let me go out here.
Oh, okay.
He was just gonna stand there.
Take it.
Look, we're getting behind us too!
That's kind of so awesome!
Wait, that's kind of so badass.
I love that.
Today is the weekend for me.
Saturday in Australia.
Good morning!
Oh my gosh.
Okay, so I've been working on this, like, bookshelf thing.
I talked about it before on stream a couple days ago, but in case you missed...
I built it on stream before.
And then, it took a really long time.
And...
I hadn't touched it for a really long time until...
Like, just the other day, and I was building it again.
More?
Why?
But, I
think maybe the rest on stream...
Because I was like, oh, well...
I started it on stream, I can finish it on stream.
I can get a lot done and then finish it on stream.
And I realized, though...
That there's a little aspect of it...
That I forgot about.
That is...
That could potentially exorcise me...
If I did it on stream.
And so...
I was like, oh shoot, well...
What do I do then?
Because I wanted to do it on stream, but if I do it on stream, it might exorcise me.
And I'm a ghost, you know, so I can't have that happen.
So I don't know!
I don't know if I'll be able to do it on stream.
But once I finish it, of course, you know, if I were to do it off stream, of course I would take a picture once I'm done with it, but...
Sorry, I just wanted to pause it.
Is he gonna do his famous jump here?
He will do the jump, right?
He'll do the jump that I need him to do, right?
He's not gonna just mess it up, right?
He'll do the jump, right?
Dante!
What is his middle name?
Oh, they're just down there.
I'll let them be.
Wait, which door do I take?
Which door do I take?
There's a door down here.
Oh gosh!
Dante spart a cry.
Cry
on the other end too?
What are you doing over there?
We got him mid-air.
Kind of awesome.
There's so many of these guys.
I'm just gonna jump down.
There we go.
Oh, Vendetta.
Oh, it's a decorative sword.
Ok guys, we wouldn't abuse it anyway.
I was gonna be like, I don't need a sword.
A decorative sword that is like death's scythe.
What the hell?
What is this guy?
He's so chill.
He's like, yeah.
He's like, yeah, I'm practicing my little...
I'm playing baby Jesus in the upcoming Christmas play at my church.
So I'm just practicing my part.
I'm being cool Jesus and all.
He's just being so chill.
Wait, is this where I came from?
What the hell is this?
Oh my gosh.
This looks like the thing that Danny Phantom goes into.
And it makes him a ghost.
He's dead tired.
Or wait, is this where I came from?
So what's over here?
Oh, the door is closed tight.
Oh, ok.
Never mind.
Never mind, I suppose.
Ok.
Alright, well we got a sword.
And let's go to the other...
Up here?
Alright.
I wish I could see any of the roofs that I walk into.
I feel like it would create much more of an impact where I'm like...
They don't consider camera angle at all.
Oh my gosh, is this really Metal Gear, you guys?
Why am I in Shadow Moses now?
Oh my god, and I got ambushed.
What is happening?
This isn't funny.
They are triggering my brain run.
Not a good way.
It's just like the area with the crows.
I'm ok.
Slow ass elevator, my god.
Prepare to fight Vulcan Raven.
Close enough.
Wait, why is it not doing it anymore?
Calm down.
Oh,
there is more.
Dead.
And just one more guy.
The sword is an actual weapon even if it says decorative.
Wait, seriously?
No, you're kidding me.
Why
did it say decorative?
I thought it was going to be used for a puzzle.
To open a door or something.
Oh my god.
This is the opposite of decorative.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
I just hit my desk in frustration.
Oh my gosh, I'm like...
I can't with this game.
Well, I guess I'll equip it.
Is it big heavy?
Oh no, it's actually not bad.
You see, this sword is actually...
I can just see the devs typing that and he's got the biggest troll face on.
He's just like, you see this sword?
It's decorative.
Oh my god.
Someone needs to bust out their dictionary.
I don't think they know what that meant.
We're going back to the oil field?
Wait.
We're going back to the oil field.
Wait, weren't we...
Huh?
Wait, what?
What the dog doing?
He's just standing there.
It's gonna blow?
No, right?
It's taking us there.
And I'm getting robs at the same time.
Making money, baby.
Why is there a beep?
It's like the sound of the...
It's transporting.
I don't really quite understand why it's beeping.
See?
We're almost there.
What?
Why don't you just stand there?
Why don't the AI do anything?
My name is Mintiplier.
I guess we're almost there.
Thank goodness.
Nice.
Another elevator!
I don't... I don't understand.
Okay, I don't think there's anything else.
Why?
Oh, we're going up!
I think this game is kind of awesome.
Get it, Dante.
Don't miss it.
Dante!
Oh my god!
Dante, don't miss it.
Just stand in the corner, Dante, and then you'll get all of them.
Okay.
Alright, just a moment guys.
I'm gonna go grab a drink.
I'm out of tea.
And I'm gonna go to the bathroom real quick.
I will be right back.
Okay.
Take a break everybody.
Take a break!
A little break time.
I'll see you guys in just a few minutes.
I'm back.
Hello everybody.
Hello.
Sorry about that.
Oh my gosh, it was so quiet.
I didn't even realize there was no music.
Sorry.
I'm back.
Sorry about that.
Oh my goodness.
I didn't even realize.
Nice and quiet.
Dante has been talking this whole time?
I bet.
I believe it.
Alrighty.
Alright, we just made it back.
We made it up.
Which way do we go?
Can't go that way.
Only one way to go.
To the helipad.
Who is this?
Oh my god, Dante is gonna talk.
Dante is gonna say something.
Oh, is that guy from Tekken?
Oh.
Oh my god.
No way.
I thought that he was gonna be like...
The guy.
Oh my gosh, we have ten minutes... Missions left after this one, right?
The challenger shall rise while the king evades.
Okay.
Dante is gonna talk!
Speak.
Speak boy.
Say something.
Oh my god, he can speak.
Maybe another time.
How did we get all the way here?
Why are we here?
What is the purpose?
Oh, this is your cover breaks up for like eight hours straight?
Stop!
Is that all he had?
That's all he said.
Oh my god.
Wait, this guy is way tinier than I thought he was.
Oh my gosh.
Get up, Dante.
Oh, they gave us...
Aim?
No, that's not where you aim.
Am I getting pulled in?
I think so.
There we go.
I forgot to get rid of the godfishen!
Sorry, I went to... Hold on.
Let me get rid of it.
There we go.
Sorry.
I was still fishing.
He is doing that again.
What am I supposed to do?
Oh my god.
I don't want to be in the air while he does that.
Do it again.
I dare you.
Cool.
I actually don't mind this.
Okay, cool.
No way.
My finger is getting tired from shooting so much.
Furryataurus.
Oh my god.
What?
There we go.
Oh my god.
Okay.
How is the weather?
It was really nice today.
I had all my windows open.
Even though it was cold.
But...
It gets kind of hot in my computer room.
Because of the computer.
So, I had my windows open.
And when I do that, my kitties like to sit there and sniff the outdoors.
It's nice.
Dante is going to say something.
Dante!
He said three lines.
The hunter will discover the purity of speed.
Are we in France?
Oh wait, or is that the oil rig?
Nevermind.
Yeah, we are still in the oil rig.
Here we go.
The cutscene was longer than the fight.
Wait, where is all my little stuff?
You promised a grorb.
It was there in the fight.
Just because I didn't...
And there was a grorb over there.
Just because I didn't grab them.
Wait, so we came all the way out here to this oil rig.
And now we are going to leave, right?
Is that actually what's happening?
Is that actually what's going on?
We can't even explore because there are invisible walls.
Oh,
an alert can be heard which means that...
Sorry.
That this building may explode at any moment.
Caution.
OK.
Oh, shoot.
I missed the ball!
Oh my god, it's so blurry.
Which way do I go?
This one has roars.
Which way is the path to take?
Warning.
Caution.
Oh no, our buddy!
No!
It was too chill to survive.
Oh my god.
I'm leaving.
Goodbye.
Warning.
Wait, I have to go up, don't I?
Ouch!
Oh, I didn't think he'd be able to get me.
OK, next one I'll just shoot it.
Warning.
Caution.
Oh, shoot.
There we go.
Oh, we were so close.
It's right there.
Warning.
Caution.
OK.
All the way over there?
And then up?
Oh my god.
Wait, wait, wait.
OK.
I'll try to remember.
All the way up?
Wait, this thing first?
Right?
This thing first?
Oh, shoot.
It's so blurry!
Warning.
Caution.
How do I do this?
Wait.
It won't let me because I'm aiming at these guys, so...
It's annoying.
Caution.
Not hitting it.
There we go.
Oh, there's more.
Somewhere.
There he is.
Oh, and there's another, and there's another.
Please!
Oh!
Just die already!
Grab my money at least.
Oh my god.
OK, there he is.
Hold RT and R2 to attack without lock-on.
Oh, really?
Hold on.
I think they're almost all dead.
Thank you though.
I appreciate it.
I think we got him.
OK.
Take my money.
Is that the only one?
Caution.
That's all we need to do, right?
There are three?
Oh.
OK.
Wait.
I think I saw one down here.
This one.
Oh, what was it?
Oh, shoot.
What did it say?
Oh my god.
Uh, R2.
OK.
Thank you.
Where's the third one at?
I only saw two of them.
Oh gosh, I'm stuck.
Further below.
OK.
There's a further below?
Like here?
Oh, I see, I see.
Warning.
Got it.
Ping pong!
Nice.
Dante!
That's counterproductive for what we're trying to do!
Oh, no, no, no.
There we go.
Just keep going, Dante.
OK.
Up there.
No!
These guys are the worst!
OK.
Nevermind.
There's a whole plane?
Oh, it's...
What the hell?
Oh my god, I'm getting sucked into this.
Oh my gosh.
To the plane!
I think...
Oh, inside.
I made it.
I'm too good at this game.
Wait.
Wait, is this not their target?
I got a...
I got a missile launcher!
Where am I supposed to go?
Is the plane not the obvious answer?
To the...
What does that mean?
What does this mean?
Oh, there we go.
I made it.
On our...
Bike...
Wait.
But this is in the middle of the ocean.
Wait, that doesn't make any sense.
We had to literally take a thing that went under the water to get here.
What?
Why didn't we just drive!?
If we could drive, why didn't we?
That doesn't make any sense.
Two lights will open the sealed door and guide the hunter to the deep underground.
What's...
How many robes are we at?
Twelve thousand.
Okay.
We got a missile launcher too.
Not bad.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Don't question the vision.
Sorry.
Now this is looking quite...
This is looking devil may cry.
This is looking familiar territory.
Where were all those robes?
I saw them all.
What the hell is this music?
Don't let it fool you.
Don't get excited now, Minto.
It's all a ruse.
Not yet.
Turn it down just a little bit more.
Hope you guys don't mind.
Flare pie romances.
I like learning the names of enemies.
Oh my gosh, the robes don't last for any amount of time.
It's crazy.
But I do appreciate that they have like...
That, at least.
To know the names of enemies and stuff.
It's always fun for me.
Even though I end up always giving them their own names anyway.
Because I can't remember what their official titles are.
Just, you know, how it goes.
Oh, thought he worked.
If you do...
I think if you do the Lucia missions, you get more of the story and a better idea as to why Dante is there.
Oh, that's kind of silly, right?
Okay.
Why do I have to do her missions?
To know why this guy...
I'm playing as Dante.
Shouldn't Dante know why Dante is there?
Okay.
Let's just start doing these then.
Oh, I've never seen that attack.
Oh, these are auro-mances.
Of course I've never seen any attack.
I'm just always blasting.
Oh, hello.
Where was that line of orbs?
I was just trying to find it.
I don't get it.
Are you okay, buddy?
You alright?
Oh, is there one more?
Pondering my orb.
Rocket launcher him?
Oh, you're right.
Oh, but it doesn't even do it in one shot.
Oh my god.
It just makes him back up.
Are those lyrics or something?
We gotta level it up.
Where's the last one?
Am I missing it?
Obviously I'm missing it, but where could it be?
Where is it?
I'm missing it somewhere.
Where are you?
Okay, hold on.
I'm just gonna look for it.
It's a timed puzzle?
That's why.
Onix, it's your birthday!
Happy birthday!
Hold on, give me one second.
No, leave me alone!
No, no, no.
There we go.
Onix, remind me though.
Remind me to sing a happy birthday, okay?
Please remind me.
Someone remind me.
Oh my god, please turn around.
Dante.
I'm gonna...
Oh my god.
How fast do I have to be?
Okay, we did it.
We did it.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, Onixwing!
Happy birthday!
Dante!
Into the hole.
Nevermind.
I
don't want him to heal.
What is this?
Oh he already healed.
This sucks.
DT and Blast them all?
So true.
DT baby!
He is just a little crabby guy now.
Can I have the carbs?
I should have saved my DT for Mothra.
Oh my god, this has a face.
Say anything!
What?
Is that it's baby?
No, it's part of him.
I think it's... No, it's not part of him.
Oh my god.
Get me out!
I'm getting bored!
Oh my
god, that took so much of my damage.
Oh my health!
Grab more health.
Corb.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
How do I switch?
How do I... Oh god, please leave me alone.
How do I switch to...
Wait, am I on...
Yeah.
Oh my god.
I'm smashing Y, I promise!
Oh my gosh, this sucks.
There we go.
No, please!
Dante, you have to...
No, I don't care about that guy.
Leave him alone.
We just have to dodge him.
There we go, there we go, there we go.
Never understood how to escape.
Seriously, there's like no way.
No good way at least, like...
Oh my gosh.
I wish I could... I wish I could shoot.
No.
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Okay.
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Okay, now I'm gonna fly, fly, fly and attack.
No, fly and attack.
Okay, that did a lot though.
So I think we're almost there, we're almost there.
Okay, oh, whoops.
I need to...
Only single attack.
And jump.
Jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Wait.
I have to defeat the larva.
No, switch attack, switch please.
This thing?
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god.
Wait, which larva?
Oh gosh.
What, what, what, what, what?
Oh my god, please.
Oh, okay, this thing.
Oh my god, jump, jump, jump, jump.
Jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna go back to... Oh my god.
I get more air time with these.
Come on, come on, come on, come on, come on, come on, come on.
Why aren't you...
Okay, I think I just got one of them.
Maybe.
Yeah, yeah.
Nice, nice.
Oh, there's more!
How many are there?
No way.
Why are there...
Okay.
Maybe this guy is the last.
Nope, maybe not.
Oh, he gave grorbs.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
Feeling better?
Feeling better now?
Okay.
That was close.
That was close!
That was so close.
I'm gonna try and DT...
Oh, no.
Oh my god, there's still more?
How many are there?
Is there a mechanic she's missing?
I have no...
Oh, shit.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, DT doesn't work.
No, no.
Melee doesn't work.
Nothing works!
No!
Okay, this might actually be the last guy.
Okay, this might actually be...
Our final guy.
Okay.
Alright.
Sorry.
I can't tell their pattern at all.
When they're gonna, like, come at me like that.
Oh, god.
That was hellish.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I didn't even get to go in...
I didn't even get to go in the hole!
Dads!
Sorry,
the music made me think I have a cat in my room.
Okay.
We have eight more...
Oh, seven!
Seven more missions.
Yay!
He wields a spear and is obeyed by the wolves.
His single eye possesses knowledge and hate.
He is the one who brings misfortune.
How many orbs I got?
Okay.
Alright.
We're fine.
I wonder...
Oh, orb is ten thousand?
No, I'm not gonna.
Alright, here we go.
Wow.
Am I going down to hell?
Again?
10k is really expensive.
I know!
Why they up the price so much in this?
Level one?
Okay.
Alright.
I'll do it.
Okay.
Alright.
Sure.
Secret room.
I thought that was an obvious door.
Like I thought that was...
Oh, wait.
These are the same guys?
Okay.
Gives you some extra orb fragments.
Let's go.
Yeah, why not?
It's easy enough, right?
Okay, these guys are so lame.
I swear.
These guys are so actually lame.
Wait, so...
Secret rooms...
Oh, wow!
Complete a secret mission.
Nice.
Look at us, guys.
So, you...
Like, if I were to have found the other ones in the other areas...
It would have been like level...
Like seven or whatever, you know?
What are these?
Oh, okay.
More of you guys.
There's more...
That guy is just standing over here.
Okay, he finally makes a move.
He's finally doing something.
Okay.
Don't worry.
It says don't worry, but I'm honestly...
I'm so unfazed.
I'm so unbothered.
Like, these guys don't even talk to me.
It's so easy.
Let's just...
Oh, I don't even have to look.
Oh, I was shooting him into space.
This floor design is...
Oh, god!
Goatling?
Okay, now I'm a little bothered.
Home decor is my passion.
Everything is just those horrible ugly tiles.
They're almost dead, though.
Come on, just a little bit more.
You know what?
There we go.
I did not...
I'm not used to having a...
A rocket launcher.
Wow!
This is truly a DIY...
Home renovation.
They're going wild on the tile.
Oh, no!
We're getting sealed in!
Crap.
Oh, that's not what I wanted.
Okay, I'm just gonna...
Oh, that's not what I meant either.
That's not what I wanted.
Wait, I want to get this thing.
Okay, nevermind.
Fly, froggy!
Fly!
More fry!
Hidden machine gun is located in...
Oh!
Hidden machine gun.
Will you help me get that?
As long as I...
I don't want to miss it.
I don't want to make...
I want to make sure.
Oh.
No, help!
They helped me with the...
With saying it was even there at all.
He, like, always leaves them on 1 HP.
Oh, just kidding.
Nevermind, I got him.
How many are there?
Freaking frogs!
The frogs!
You want to see me use my sword more?
I can do that.
Said no one ever.
Who wants me to use my sword more?
Okay, so here...
Oh, that doesn't look...
Okay, hold on.
Um...
Uh...
More in here.
What...
Room?
Um...
This room?
I can...
Have rewarded me.
Said good job, Minto.
You discovered.
The extra orbs.
Okay, in here.
Extra orbs?
None.
We reward your...
In here.
Okay, okay, hold on.
I'm going in every damn little tiny window.
No!
We reward your...
Tenacity.
And...
Um...
And your...
Ability to explore.
I think you missed one.
But it didn't look like anything was in there.
Is there actually anything in there?
Please.
Dante.
Dante!
Guys, I don't think I'm gonna find the machine gun...
Unless anybody tells me where it's at.
I have no idea.
Cool.
Thank you.
These things, I wish they were like the bats...
And had...
Like could be killed in one shot.
Instead they're actual enemies.
I hate that.
Oh.
No help?
Okay then.
I just won't get it.
That's no problem.
Unless I run into it on accident.
Not a single thought in that head.
Nope.
Not a single thought.
I'm just trying to...
I was like...
I was mostly like...
Man, I wanna play too so I can...
Well, obviously see how it plays.
Everybody always, you know, rags on the gameplay.
I also was just like...
What kind of story is there?
And I just don't...
I don't know!
I still have many questions!
I don't know anything!
Oh my god, please.
Dante.
I think I'm gonna kill you.
Dante, I swear to god.
Just jump on...
Just jump on the door, please!
I don't even know which way I need to go!
Oh no, I went back the same way.
How is that poss...
How is that possible?
This is the way I did before.
What?
That's the door?
That's the way I came in, isn't it?
Isn't this the door that I came in?
Oh.
The pillar spun.
Yeah, I knew something opened, but I thought...
Well, you know what?
If the camera angle was better...
I would be able to know that!
I made it.
Glad I wasn't on headphones.
If it helps you get through this log, Dante has one...
Really sick one-liner at the final boss fight.
It's the only time he'll...
Wait, this is not the door out, is it?
This is just a money door.
I guess that's good too.
I only need...
Oh no.
It's just a little side room.
Indiana Jones?
Wait, actually!
Really?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he actually hits?
These guys actually fight?
It's a ranged attack.
Wait no, get the other guy first please.
Get this guy.
Get Torso first.
No!
That's why I said get Torso first!
Oh my gosh.
Try
to kill him first.
Kill this guy.
Kill him and then we can kill him.
I didn't...
I didn't even jump.
What happened?
How did I fly in the air like that?
CT?
Nah, it's okay.
I don't need to.
I just need to shoot him.
It's all good.
And we're done.
Give me my money.
Thank you.
Okay, goodbye.
Okay, now I think...
Hold on.
Equip.
Amulet.
Move faster.
What's the other one we have?
Oh, okay.
We have the lightning.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
Alright, I think I might have to DT for this...
This thing though.
Oh, I couldn't roll.
True, true.
Did that kill me?
Dante!
Uh...
The guns were back there.
Well...
Oh, I can go back and check.
Nevermind.
Um, that was weird.
Oh.
Wait, I wanna try...
Get in here, Dante!
I guess those don't break open.
Can I see where I'm going or...
What I'm...
How...
How?
Above the thing you slashed?
Oh, they're up.
I can't see anymore.
Oh.
Like up here?
Ow!
Hold on.
Oh my god.
Okay, I can't slash that.
I don't know where I'm supposed to go.
Like, it showed me a thing, but...
I'm confused by this thing.
I'm confused by it.
And I can't see anything!
I can't...
I...
Why am I...
Oh, maybe here.
Okay, hold on.
Please.
Show me camera.
Oh.
Here, here, here, here.
No!
This is where I just was!
Just kidding.
Oh my god!
Above here?
Oh gosh.
How am I supposed to get above?
I can't see anything.
I'm trying!
I'm trying, you guys.
I'm trying.
I can't see anything.
How is there anything above?
I'm so confused, you guys.
I'm seriously...
I don't know.
The wall...
You know the walls are four sided!
By the red orb room.
This is for the exit, right?
This is not for something stupid!
I fell.
Okay, I don't care anymore.
What is this thing?
Please.
Oh my god, I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die.
I'm free.
I don't care about the gun so much.
What?
No more platforming.
No more...
Bang!
Wait, does that one also give me anything?
Now you grab the ledge, Dante!
I hate this game.
I thought you were a parkour pro in Minecraft.
Why don't you guys understand?
Minecraft...
Is not the real world!
I think I can just get back on top of it though.
Now, how do I...
Okay, there are things in the air.
Okay game, show me!
The things...
Oh, okay, okay.
Do I go up from here or over?
Oh, away, away.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
The camera becomes so stiff here.
Is there anything?
What's over here?
Oh, okay, okay.
I could have gone either way I guess.
You bitch.
You bitch!
Bitch!
Was it this one?
Which is the one that I got to?
Which was the one I started at?
I don't even know anymore.
You can fly man.
What's up here?
This looks like secret.
Big money, big money.
These dolls are so creepy.
No?
No money?
When the money?
Okay, Ruth.
It's a puzzle.
Let's keep going.
So we can get a new power-up!
Oh my gosh, we have to figure this out.
Okay, hold on.
This one kind of looks like me.
I don't see anything that like...
2, 4, 6.
1, 2.
1, 2, 3, 4.
I hope it's not in a combo.
5, 6, 7.
Oh shit.
1, 2.
Oh, nevermind.
What?
Do I kiss it two times?
Somehow Mint's bug eyes are piercing through my soul.
Oh my god.
Wait, this guy's got arms...
He's got arms.
He's got eyeballs on his arms!
Oh my god.
Skip it Mint, please.
I beg of you.
Why doesn't someone just tell me the answer?
And then I can get the power-up.
Break all three of them fast before they respawn.
What?
You have to break all three simultaneously?
Oh?
You do?
Really?
In order?
Wait, how?
How do you do that?
Blinders!
Welcome to Manbush Appanku!
Oh my god.
No!
We were so...
We were so close.
Oh my god.
What?
Do guns work too?
Oh, shit.
No, that's not what...
No, please.
No, only melee.
Oh my god, I'm not close enough.
That wasn't fast enough.
DT slashes do more damage.
So you can do that to deal more damage.
Okay.
Oh my god.
No, no, stop, stop.
What the hell?
Oh, I...
Nevermind.
I guess.
I give up.
Where are we?
Oh yeah, we go downstairs.
Okay.
No, you had it?
I don't... I did not.
No.
No, that's not true.
I did not.
Am I a joke to you?
No, it's because there's this hole.
Okay, what is the power-up anyway?
Is it something I'll ever use?
What is this?
If anybody knows.
Why did you skip over the optional puzzle?
Chrono Amulet.
Rebellion swings faster?
Does it do more damage?
Faster regen.
That's it?
Come on!
It
wasn't fully regenerated!
It wasn't fully regenerated.
That's so messed up.
Wait, stop turning around you piece of shit Dante!
I literally have my analog stick literally facing towards this thing.
Wait, nothing happened.
Oh my god!
Hello?
Give me a second!
Oh my god!
I just got here!
It didn't even give me a chance to move!
Oh my god!
Oh, what gun am I using?
There we go.
That's why.
Okay, back to actual... I wasted too much time on all of that.
I'm so upset right now.
I wasted so much time on all of that.
Here I am just trying to get through this damn game.
Oh, stop!
Oh my god, this thing... This spear is too crazy.
Oh my god, it's too crazy.
In a better game it would have been worth it.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god!
Fuck it.
The wolf sounds so much like SniperWolf's wolves, I can't get over it.
I know it's just wolf sound, but it still makes me laugh.
Don't jump?
Okay, I won't jump.
But then dogs come after me.
I'm gonna die.
I'm not gonna make it.
What the hell?
Why is it a different move all of a sudden?
That was weird.
There's a grorb, you're right.
Ouch.
Okay, thanks for giving me a second to collect myself.
Oh my god, I tried to avoid him.
I should have rolled instead of...
Well, rolling doesn't do anything either apparently.
Give me some iframes or something, man.
Oh my god, I can't do this.
I hate this guy.
Oh my god.
Stop!
Stop with the wolf!
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Unfair!
Oh my god, I dodged that.
I dodged it though.
I love how I said I dodged that though and someone was like, no you didn't.
Why do you guys hate me so much?
By saying I dodged it, I said...
Why do I have to explain myself to you?
It's fine.
Everything's fine.
I don't care anymore.
Well, you didn't.
I meant that I pressed the dodge button.
Oh,
there we go.
Okay, next mission.
Mission 12.
When the hunter and the protector meet, the last mystery will be given and received.
Okay, I'm gonna go get my eye drops real quick because I haven't blinked this entire stream and my eyes are really dry.
So give me one second.
I'll be right back.
Okey doker.
I dripped it all over my face.
I did it again.
Thank you guys for the superchats!
Blindness, thanks for the superchat earlier.
Happy to finally be able to join in superchat.
Thank you!
You didn't have to.
Why are you playing DMC2?
Because I can't say I'm a fan of something if I don't play the entire series.
It's how I exist.
I gotta do completion sake.
Most fans skip 2.
That's their problem.
If I say, hey, remember that part in 2 that was just such absolute suffering and someone goes...
Oh no, I skipped 2.
I'll be like...
I won't do it again.
Whoops, I dropped it.
Thank you.
Okay, mission!
Wait, how much orbs did I have?
Sorry, I meant to check.
26!
Oh my gosh, we're so close.
We're so close to level 3.
Let's go.
Maybe next level?
Mission 12.
12.
Okay.
What the heck is this?
I'll take your word for it when it comes to Metal Gear Assassin.
Oh my gosh!
Hey, stop distracting me with Metal Gear.
Wait, how the fuck do I do this?
Oh my god,
what is this?
What is this?
I don't like this.
What the hell?
Sargassi?
Sargassi, please!
So I just... What the?
What?
Oh my god, how do I avoid hitting this thing?
I don't understand!
Hit the gems?
Oh...
Oh my god,
please.
I can't... I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die.
At least we just started.
Oh my god, I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die for real.
I died for real.
Oh, and...
Wait, are they gonna come back around?
Push my body!
Okay, now it looks normal.
Okay.
Gosh, this...
He hit me instead.
Okay, so they go along the sides.
Okay, I see.
Now I see.
I was like, how?
The camera angle was so weird for me.
I couldn't tell what I was hitting or where I was.
Everything... Okay, nice.
We got another one.
Okay, I'm just gonna keep... Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch!
Leave me alone, please!
Once you are out of the range...
Okay, nice.
Nice, nice.
Don't worry!
Oh, he's spitting at me.
Oh, shit, shit, shit, shit.
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nope, nope, not... I didn't jump enough!
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
It does so much big damage!
Nice, nice.
He was around too much for me to feel like I...
You can fly above him, because that's what I was doing...
Oh, shoot.
Before...
Oh, shit.
Come on.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
But I also died before, so...
I just kept getting... Oh, shoot.
No, no, no.
Oh, I rolled on accident, that's why.
At least the skelly is leaving me alone.
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
Oh my god, please.
Why can't I just lock on to these things?
Okay.
Generous.
I'm not used to this kind of generosity.
I don't think I got any rorbs from that entire fight, which is really great.
I'll get rorbs now!
Yes.
What's the other way?
Hold on.
Bad boss ahead?
Oh, no.
Is that the same door?
Oh, it's the same door.
Okay, just kidding.
Save?
I don't think it'll do anything.
I have no yorbs.
I'd have to go through the first guy again.
But, whatever.
I'll just save anyway.
She!
Whatever.
Save!
This is nonsensical.
I have no idea why we're here...
Who this is...
What we're doing...
Like, what is that?
Why are we in this location?
Oh my god.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
Okay, there's a... Alright, there's a...
Okay, cool.
I'll stay back here.
Okay, that's fine.
DT to win?
Thank you for the Aqua Super!
Wait, hold on.
Doing a fancy restaurant.
Squeaky screams.
No!
Wait, hold on!
I can't...
I can't read it, though.
Wait, I can't tell if bad boss meant like... I thought you guys meant tough.
Oh, it got a little longer.
Is it getting longer?
Or am I crazy?
Did it get longer?
Oh my gosh!
Oh, that was close.
Ouch!
Oh my god.
I don't think it's that he's walking towards me.
I think they're actually...
Oh my god.
Wait, he's now in like the middle of the room, so it's kind of actually tough.
Okay, hold on.
We need to get him.
I think he was like, allocating...
The... What's it called?
You know, like the chain?
For one.
And like, making it... So it made the other one longer, you know what I mean?
He's walking?
Oh, is that just all?
I wish these guys would... Oh, yeah, they're short again.
You can hit the lackeys.
Stupid lackeys.
Oh, that was close.
Oh, that was so close!
See, he makes it longer.
Unless he just moves closer.
The more he throws.
Ouch.
Oh my god, he is an absolute tank.
Tank of a man.
Good lord.
That's not what I wanted to do.
Please stop summoning guys, it's annoying me.
Oh my god, he is such a tank.
Oh, and now he's... Okay, there we go.
I like how this guy was running towards me.
Oh, that was close.
Kill you.
It's okay, we'll get more DT the more we kill these guys.
Guys.
Ouch!
Oh my god.
I didn't realize you could do one after another like that.
Oh my god, there's too many guys.
DT.
Oh god, we haven't even gotten to the red!
Holy mo...
Oh...
Close, close, close.
Close to red.
At least.
No!
I landed in the worst possible spot.
I was trying to get over to the side of the room.
Wombo combo.
Let's get more... Oh, oh, gosh.
That was close.
More DT.
DT on the guy.
Okay, very cool.
Yeah, very fun.
Yeah, we know.
Very cool.
Okay.
Just a little bit more.
Oh my god.
These guys come charging for me.
They're on a mission.
Gotta get to the other side of the room.
Yeah,
I knew you were gonna do that.
Okay.
Alright.
Shoot, shoot, shoot.
Shoot, shoot, shoot!
Doesn't
matter.
Yeah, take this guy out.
Take this guy out.
Give me more DT.
Give me more DT power up.
Okay, just a little bit more and I'll do another one.
Oh my god, close.
Ah, shoot!
Oh my god, he can't even get me in the air.
Messed up.
Okay.
He like, walks.
I don't understand how he walks.
Because he's not.
I think it's like the momentum pushing him forward, right?
A bad boss indeed.
Yeah, this actually sucks.
I thought I was fine.
And then...
I just realized...
I'm not fine.
Oh my god.
Like, why can't you stay over there, you freak?
Derogatory.
Very slowly approaching.
He approach.
And I have to fight these bozos...
Instead of just shooting him.
While he's like so far away, you know?
And so he ends up getting all nice and close and cozy with me.
I don't like that!
If I just touch his balls, is it gonna hurt me?
Genuine question.
Sorry for the phrasing.
But, actual question.
Like, if they're just there and I walk up into them...
If I just approach him, if I just accidentally, you know...
I wanna stay...
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
No.
Okay, okay, hold on.
Alright.
I'm gonna DT.
We're gonna...
Oh, nevermind.
I'm not gonna DT.
I wanted to while he was far away.
I wanted to while he was far.
Okay, now I can.
What?
What is this?
Oh my god.
Oh, we're getting into the final parts of the battle now, eh?
Yeah?
Oh my gosh.
Grid base.
This is why I love the pistols, because I...
If I go up into the air, I'm in the air for a minute, usually.
Oh, I say as I come back down really quickly.
Go away!
Go, go.
And they're fast now.
They're so fast.
Oh my gosh, I couldn't even see.
This is so unfair.
I can't...
Oh my god, please.
From the angle, I can't even see.
Oh my gosh.
Please kill the guys.
Kill the minions.
I don't care.
Kill these bozos.
Another thing.
Okay.
I'm gonna DT in...
Now!
Oh my god.
I'm taking damage, but it's okay.
Just go!
The grind.
Give me big money for that.
I swear.
The other side?
Okay.
Goodness.
Get me out of there.
And we came to this place and...
Now we're leaving.
Oh yeah, grandma.
Final?
I obtained eight...
What?
What's the story?
Okay.
Granny.
Oh, it's Lucia.
This guy sucks.
Your lucky streak continues, Granny.
Show us Dante.
Is it really?
Or are you just being a sensitive man?
15 minute boss...
Or 16 minute boss.
Gosh.
Alright.
30,000 you guys!
We can upgrade our guns!
Let's go power up!
Reach level 3 on any gun with Dante.
Alright.
The hunter will learn to feel with a leap of faith.
We're back in Brazil, I guess.
Oh no.
I don't think she did a very good job.
Okay.
It does look like Heihachi.
That's what I was talking about earlier.
Mint, are you still shooting?
That's just a piece of crap.
He's literally holding it in his hand.
He didn't put it in a backpack, a purse or anything.
He's like, I'm gonna carry this all the way to Brazil.
But...
Your swan song will.
Oh my god.
He's summoning the...
Hold on.
I'm trying to lower...
Okay, there we go.
Alright.
Your swan song will.
Where'd the girl go?
Is she up there?
Oh yeah, she's still up there.
Where is this fancy place that we're at?
Oh, he's summoning more.
This guy sucks.
Okay.
You got some tricks?
I can see you got some tricks.
You've got some...
Okay.
Maybe I should...
The one thing that hits me is...
I have bullets.
He's smoking.
No, don't focus on that guy.
Who cares about him?
Step away from the girl.
He's just sitting there.
Oh my god.
Oh, okay.
Alright, first it was just some little guys...
And then you're like, I'm sending in the big boys.
I wish these things had a...
Health bar though.
I'm mashing.
It's okay, we're getting DT.
Where did the goat go?
Is she still around?
Oh, there he is.
Okay.
You have really bad camel toe.
What?
Lucia.
Lucia?
That was her name?
Okay.
You should've killed him though.
Nice, DT.
Good thing I have that power.
Good thing that power wasn't gate kept behind a stupid ass puzzle...
That I did technically beat and then it told me I didn't.
Good thing, right?
Alright.
Alright guys, mission 13.
This is like Dante's best outfit.
I wish it didn't suffer being stuck in this game.
It is really good.
Hmm.
What?
That's your dad?
Or...
There's still time.
Through the front door.
Four lights will open the door to the future and the past.
Well, that's how we open the door everybody.
It explained it for us.
Oh, it's max.
My gun is max now.
Wow.
I could get... Well, no.
I can't get a orb.
You can only have one gold orb at a time.
This game is messed up.
This game is so messed up.
Four more missions.
Yeah, only four more.
That's right.
Oh.
Dutch angle.
We're a little crooked.
We went... We were... Okay, hold on.
I want to explore this way.
But we were walking in the opposite direction.
It's eclipsed.
So we have to find the four lights.
Abyss goat?
Abyss goat.
Oh yeah.
Look how much more damage we're doing now.
So good.
Oh, there's a couple guys.
That's okay.
A biscuit.
We're doing the big damage.
The big monies.
Well, maybe not the big monies, but who cares.
Okay, good.
This is gameplay.
What is that?
Ziggy!
Thanks for the super chat.
Blood goat.
Oh, I think they're behind the wall.
This is that city.
Oh, there's two of them.
Thank you so much for the five gifted.
Okay, I have to look or else I'm gonna...
I'm gonna get shot at.
And that's no fun.
Oh, hello.
Oh my gosh.
Can they do something else?
This is so annoying.
Blood goat.
Die, blood goat.
Wait, where did the other guy go?
He just floated away.
I never got to finish killing him.
What?
What happened to that guy?
Oh, there he is.
I was like...
What happened to the abyss goat?
Oh shoot, I hate these guys so much.
I'm just gonna keep running.
We're just gonna run, you guys.
He ran just like me.
I can't see anything.
Why is the camera like this?
Okay.
Alright, we just gotta find...
The lights, right?
Four of them?
Couple of them?
Four, give or take.
Let's just keep running.
Oh my god.
They were like, yeah, Resident Evil camera.
What the hell?
I'm looking...
What is this?
This is the exact mission where I drop the game.
Follow them.
Follow the robs.
Okay.
I love not knowing where I'm going.
Love it, love it, love it.
I found one!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my gosh.
Please.
Just go for the savage.
You know what?
Goodbye.
Please.
What?
There's more of you guys?
Oh my god, there's... Oh wait, that's the same guy.
Okay.
Wait.
And then he regenerated, which is so awesome.
Love that.
Love when that happens.
Go to the other guy.
Go to the other...
Okay, now they're both regenerated.
No, not quite.
Okay, hold on.
Please.
No!
He's gonna regenerate!
Leave the little babies!
I don't care about the babies!
Leave the babies!
Okay.
There we go.
Alright, we at least got one of them.
Oh my god.
There's another guy!
There's always spawning another guy.
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no.
What is it?
Right trigger?
Oh, shoot.
I can't... I can't aim.
I can't aim for shit.
Ferocity, please!
Lower them.
I guess I could try and kill one, but I'm afraid another one will just spawn instead.
Let's try the rocket launcher!
Maybe another one won't launch.
Maybe I'm just being paranoid.
Another one won't spawn.
Maybe it's okay.
Oh, it's okay!
Oh my gosh, it's okay.
That's right, Dante.
Light it up, baby!
Come on, Dante!
Yeah!
The movement of the demon world is slowly intensifying!
You need to release three more powers in order to reach the demon world!
The demon world!
We came from that way, so let's go down this way.
That's a lot of orbs.
Anyway...
I think I will buy...
I'll save for the plorb.
It's fine.
Save for the plorb.
Okay, we can't go in there.
The area is not good anymore, right?
The side told us everything.
You're one of us, Mint.
There it is!
I don't know how I did that, but...
Oh my gosh, please.
No, no, no!
There we go.
Nice.
Death, death, death, death, death, death, death, death, death, death.
Oh gosh, ouchie, ouchie, ouchie.
What the hell is the Brontomancer?
What does he do?
Oh my god.
He shoots bronts.
This guy is...
The Oramancers are decreasing my aura!
Okay.
What is that?
Jump, jump.
Oh, it's thunder.
Home, home, home.
Okay.
You can feel the movement of the demon world intensifying even more!
You need to release two more powers in order to reach the demon world.
So what?
Is this a door or something?
Or is this the demon world?
Oh, this is a door.
Evil roar.
I like how there is a staircase up to the...
It's just a big old starfish.
We'll leave that there.
I don't think I'm supposed to be here yet.
Maybe.
Patrick has seen better days.
Really now?
Because, I mean...
What the hell?
I think he's looking like he's, you know...
Got it all figured out for himself.
You know, he's a giant star.
He's grown so big.
He's even got little eyeballs now.
Well, I guess he always had eyeballs.
Was it this door?
Oh wait, down here.
We didn't go.
Or guess I...
No.
Wait, is this where I started?
Yes it is.
Oh my god.
I just went in a big ass circle.
There's one on the rooftops.
Okay, thank you.
Oh my gosh, I hate these abyss...
Oh, I see it!
Oh my gosh, I see it.
Thank you.
Ouch!
It kicked me in the air.
You didn't see it?
I got it.
I know where it is.
I saw it.
That's all that matters, right?
As long as I see it...
Then we can get it.
I don't know how to get it yet.
What?
There's another goat?
How many goats are there?
That should be all of them.
Okay.
How do we get all the way up here?
See it up there?
All the way up there.
Okay, hold on.
Let's go this way.
And then...
This way.
Can I go from here?
No.
Ah!
Free Roar for the way home.
No!
Ah!
Okay.
You can feel the movement of the demon world intensifying to extreme!
You need to release one more power in order to reach the demon world!
Extreme demonics.
Where is the last one?
This is where there was water.
I'm trying to think.
It's in a weird place, is it?
I'm trying to think of a...
I guess I'll just circle back around and see...
Where I've gone to and where not.
These lights have nothing to do with it, right?
Oh, come on.
Oh my god.
I'm trying to leave, but I can't.
I'm trying to leave.
Let me know if I pass it.
Over around here.
Don't worry.
It's a place I haven't looked at yet.
Where is that?
A place I haven't looked at yet.
Didn't I have to go...
Yeah!
I remember having to go through here before.
I see it!
I am also smart!
The Bromancer!
That's why I said the leap of faith or whatever.
Where is the Bromancer?
Wait, there is also a hidden thing.
There is also a new power-up.
Bromancer!
Oh my gosh.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
OK, you know what?
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
I just wanted to kill the Bromancer.
There are so many guys.
Give me your money.
They all have to die eventually.
Wait, what's this?
Merciless?
Collect all swords with Dante.
A sword with snakes engraved.
It's not powerful, but it has a wide range attack.
It kind of sucks, but...
You know, it works.
Oh!
Remake makes you the Viper Captain!
At least it's honest.
What do we get?
You have the swords, but you're missing the machine gun.
I don't care!
Healing heart.
A magic stone with the heart of a merciful goddess.
I'm gonna... Wait.
I thought the other one was healing.
C2!
C3!
Thanks for the five gifts.
You will be able to reach the demon world.
Okay.
Now do I go to Patrick Star again?
Maybe the other one was ice.
Oh.
Nevermind.
Spooked me.
I thought we were...
Do I go back to Patrick Star?
No?
Say hi to Manta Rock!
Was it this way?
Yeah.
It was this way.
No.
Actually, I don't know which way.
La la la!
Don't pay attention!
If you miss a gun, a weapon or an amulet, you can get it back in a later mission.
Oh yeah!
Wait.
This way.
Right?
Down the little alleyway?
Dante!
Okay.
Chill.
Yeah, yeah.
Over here.
What does it mean?
Oh!
Manta Rock Barcode.
Nasty.
Okay.
I guess we are going to the demon world.
Into the demon hole.
No.
This game is trolling.
This game is trolling me right now.
No way.
This game is trolling me!
I want to sting her so bad.
He's not doing anything though.
Hey!
You were so much freakier in the other game.
What's wrong with you?
What's wrong?
Why don't you do anything?
Oh.
There we go.
Don't worry.
The power has already been released.
It appears to supply the demon pulse to the gate below.
Okay.
What?
Thanks?
Oh, ouch.
You distracted me!
You threw off my groove!
Oh, come on.
That's awkward.
I want to get the... Well, I guess I don't need the orb right now.
Oh gosh!
Phantom, please.
The phantom pain real.
Why did I feel like I was going to become a...
There we go.
Defeated Phantom!
What?
That's it?
I can't believe that this clear time...
Is shorter then some of the bosses...
It hurts.
Alright.
3 more missions left.
15, 16... Oh no, four more missions.
15, 16, 17, 18.
Four more missions!
They swarm like clouds and desperately seek the hunter's dark blood.
Plorb time.
Nice.
Phantom on phantom violence.
We're almost free.
See, that's what I said, remember guys?
Five hours and then give a couple hours, you know?
That also takes into account... What's my health?
Wait.
What's my health like?
Oh, full.
It helps when I take a break, when I talk, when I explore, all that stuff.
Better check the lump.
There's a lump?
Where's a lump?
Web-covered lump, this?
The pimple?
This pimple right here?
Why do I check that?
This little nipple.
What are you, into pimple popping?
You haven't really beaten DMC2 until you also do Lucina's route.
I think that you are a liar.
What's her name?
Lucia?
I can't remember.
I don't remember how to pronounce it.
Hello?
Lucia?
Isn't it the same exact game though?
But... Oh my gosh.
What the hell?
What is this?
What do you mean by a time limit?
Why do I only have 3 minutes?
Oh my god.
What do you mean I only have 3 minutes?
For what?
Same game but in reverse.
Wait, actually...
Oh my gosh.
You know what?
Why am I crazy?
Oh!
Okay.
I see you, John.
I see you.
Kill him!
Death.
To all 3 of you.
And then... Oh, more of you.
No.
Oh, you still... No, nevermind.
Where is it?
Oh
my gosh.
More!
The Abyss Ghosts!
No!
Is it just survive or do I have to kill everything in the time?
I don't know.
Just survive?
Okay.
I hope you are not wrong.
We only have 30 seconds.
Oh gosh.
I'm scared!
I'm killing!
Wait.
Is it survive or kill?
Some people are saying different things.
KILL?!
No, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I didn't save!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
Oh my gosh.
That would have been so bad.
Alright.
Let's go!
Oh my gosh!
Okay, as soon as I have good stuff to double trigger, I should.
That's such a tight time frame.
Die, die, die, baby, die, baby.
Die, baby.
Die, little baby.
Maybe someone will drop a little...
A little... What's it called?
Thing to boost, you know?
Oh my gosh.
Where is the other guy, please?
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
Oh god.
No, no, no, no.
Jump, jump, jump!
Die, Obstacle.
Oh my gosh.
Why did I get downed by a monkey?
Stop touching me!
What's this?
No time!
Wait, time ran out?
Wait, just keep going?
Try again?
I thought it said I had a minute left.
Wait, what?
I'm so confused.
Maybe I read the wrong part of the...
Otherwise, I would've...
I was like, wow, I have so much time left.
Attack the eyes?
Wait, is that actually a thing?
The
enemies are different, so...
I don't know what's going on.
I don't... I don't know what's going on, man.
What the hell am I trying to find?
Oh, it's this sucker.
Oh god.
Fuck it.
Oh, I saw more guys.
Guys,
I don't think I'm gonna make it again.
No.
Guys, I don't think I'm gonna make it again.
Wait, did I make it?
I thought there were three routes!
Do I go in?
Okay.
I made it somehow!
I said this many rounds, VTuber!
Oh my gosh, I can't believe you were playing the game and not reading chat, VTuber.
I told you.
VTuber, did you not see my comment I wrote in the chat?
Two rounds on the second try.
Did you not see while you were playing the video game, VTuber?
Oh my gosh, I told you.
I thought you were supposed to read every single chat that comes in your view.
Which should be your entire...
What's the point of having two eyes if you can't read chat and also play the game at the same time?
Your eyes are going in different ways, VTuber.
You should be able to do multi things at once.
What's wrong with you?
Notice me, VTuber.
Hi, Alex.
Minto, are you okay?
Yeah, I'm fine.
We are almost done with the game.
I'm feeling good.
Mission 16.
Chaos ripens as the hunter runs towards the sky.
Okay.
How much raw arms do I got?
12,000!
You guys...
12,000 raw arms!
Should I get more purple orb?
Fifteen!
Hey VTuber, I was cooking.
Why don't you do that?
Why didn't you do that thing?
Why?
Where are we?
What?
Maybe I should have gotten some devil... whatever.
The purple ones.
VTuber, why so cute when angry?
Where am I going?
Oh my god.
No, Dante.
Is there not a door?
I'm styling.
Maybe I go through here.
Oh, just kidding.
I have to activate it first.
Oh my god.
I don't feel like dealing with you right now.
You know, I don't feel like dealing with you right now.
Oh my god, there are so many appearing.
Yo, the demon world is crazy.
Hi VTuber.
Hi!
Is there a way to parry?
I thought I would be able to do it.
What?
Kill!
Blood for
the...
Hello?
Oh there we go.
Oh my gosh, Metal Gear.
Wait, launch the missile!
Why isn't it launching the missile?
Why isn't my missile launcher working?
Thank you for noticing me VTuber.
Oh, there it is.
Do I get hurt from the missile too?
I can't tell.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, it doesn't work mid-air.
That makes sense.
Bro, bro, bro!
Do you see them like freeze and they go like with their hands up?
So silly.
What's over here?
There's money in here, that's what there is.
Real question is, does the missile know where it is?
If so, how?
Does she know about the Resident Evil fact yet?
No, I don't.
Is this game related to Resident Evil?
Please tell me how.
Someone tell me, someone tell me.
This is Resident Evil 6.
Inhaled.
So, this is going to be Resident Evil Village.
Do I need devil stars?
Wait, this way.
This place is fancy.
Feels like some puppets are going to drop down.
I'll be honest though guys, I've been fighting a headache.
I don't know why.
Some days I just... Some days...
Some days I just get a bad headache.
I've been fighting it for a couple of hours but...
I've just been like, I want to get through the game so...
I might have to go take some medicine soon, I think.
I can't see!
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Oh.
Anyway.
Sacrilege.
This will generate distortion and bring the world closer to the demon...
We're not in the demon world yet.
What do you mean?
But I...
Sending you energy so your head gets better.
Thank you.
But I thought we...
The
point of it all then...
Of this Patrick!
Oh my god!
Blorb!
My health.
Nice.
I have no clue where we are.
Me neither.
Is this not a door?
Is this a door?
Is mayonnaise an instrument?
What do I do with this heart?
Oh, here.
You put the sacrilege with evil statue.
Maybe this is a good game.
Oh my god.
Oh, I don't want this one.
Oh my goodness.
New pyromaniac you!
Oh!
Hello.
Sorry, I didn't notice you.
Speak up next time.
Gosh, too quiet.
Okay.
We have two ways we can go.
This way and this way.
Let's go this way first.
No!
Don't steal my aura!
I think we got him.
My aura kind of sucks.
Why?
There was nothing in there.
I lied?
We got the machine gun!
Wait, but it's a cell machine gun.
It's a little different.
Is that the one from before?
They were just in a vase.
That's where I keep all my guns.
Oh, thanks.
I got all the guns, but I don't get an achievement.
I got all the swords and I get an achievement, but no achievement for all the guns.
That doesn't make much sense.
I also sent ace combat brain rot and lore too.
Thank you.
Oh, there is one more.
I see.
Guys, I'm so lost.
Wait, huh?
Am I going in circles?
Sort of.
Okay, hold on.
Go left.
I hope I'm not... Marshall, you better not be one-guying me.
I swear.
Marshall, I know your name.
I can search you.
I can find you.
What's a really full version of sneeder?
So, left.
Left.
I feel like the more I try to avoid these guys, the more I get hit.
You know what I mean?
When I'm jumping, I'm like, oh yeah, I'm trying to play a game here.
I'm trying to jump around and have style.
But really, just whacking and shooting is...
I guess the right way to do it instead.
Wait, you mean I'm dyslexic.
There really was a full version of sneeder.
How am I dyslexic?
I read it right?
Guys, I think we are in the devil room.
I think we are getting close.
Oh my god.
No!
Oh shoot.
I shouldn't have jumped.
Oh my gosh.
Why were you just standing there?
Oh, I killed him.
Sorry, sniper wolf.
Oh my gosh.
Oh,
I didn't see that he was coming towards me.
Oh my god, please.
I just got up.
You know what?
Screw it.
Fine.
Oh my gosh.
Please.
Oh, come on.
I can't see.
Oh my gosh.
How am I supposed to know what you are about to do if I can't fucking see you?
Please!
This is so gross.
I can't escape you guys.
I'm actually trapped.
Oh my gosh.
I don't care.
I don't want to die here.
Oh my god.
No, no, no.
Don't jump!
Don't jump Dante!
Oh my gosh.
I'm trapped.
I can't see.
I can't see anything.
Where is he?
Why is the camera angle like this?
Why can't I see anything?
Oh my god.
I can't see a thing.
Please camera angle.
Why?
Why is it like this?
Just shoot.
Just shoot baby.
I'm not hitting him though.
I don't know where he is.
Where did he go?
Why am I not hitting him?
Oh my god.
What's happening?
What is he doing?
Oh, that's why I'm not hitting him.
There we go.
Oh gosh.
Camera was the real boss.
I was like, why can't anyone...
What's happening?
I'm having the worst luck walking into a room and having to fight Fuwamuko...
and their demonic handler.
It's a good job considering the unfair circumstances.
Thank you!
Sacrilege.
This will generate distortion and bring the world closer to the demon world.
Can we go back this way?
Nope.
Okay.
Alright.
Evil statue.
Eat it.
Oh my gosh.
We are so close to the demon world.
That's crazy.
More guys.
Guys on the wall.
Guys on the floor.
Guys in my brain.
Little brain worms everywhere.
Oh, nevermind.
The guy is already dead.
This way?
Follow the orbs?
What is that?
Oh my gosh.
It's so dark.
I can't even see anything in here though.
Person who... Wait.
Who names of these enemies at a stroke.
Yeah!
Die!
Oh, another Abyss God.
Of course there is always at least several of them.
There is always several of them.
Now focus on the Abyss God.
No!
Don't break the combo.
These things break my combo with these guys.
It's so annoying.
I'm Dark Souls right now.
I'm Dark Souls.
Oh, I think I got him.
Okay.
Gosh, please.
The SMGs?
What am I...
They do barely anything though.
Is he just gonna lie there?
There is actually no way.
There is actually no way that just happened.
I'm gonna turn it down.
Put the sacrilege with the evil statue.
How many more do we need?
Oh, wait.
How many more?
Oh!
I think we are in the demon world.
It didn't tell us anything.
Okay, this guy doesn't give up.
This guy doesn't have a death wish.
Oh, okay.
I missed my other guns.
They actually do damage.
Looks pretty human to me.
No, a little bit, but like...
I'm just gonna ignore.
Let's go this way.
I'm going this way.
I'm going in here.
Goes to make cry.
Oh no, we are not in the demon world.
Where are we?
This is the human...
I sure hope those guys don't wake up.
That would truly make a devil cry.
Hey, chill out.
Come down here and fight me.
He's not even looking at me.
This guy is...
Okay, let's see if it happens.
Oh, whoops.
Give up!
Is this a sacrilege?
Oh, what?
I think that's the first time I've seen like a loading screen.
No, it's a...
Oh, it's one of these.
Okay, it's a power-up thing.
Paid actor demon.
What did we get?
We got a...
Oh, we got the ice one!
Then what was the other one?
A beautiful ice demon.
Let's go.
What was the other one?
We'll never know.
I think.
Okay.
Where have I not gone?
This way.
I don't have time to deal with you guys!
Wait, this way?
Oh, this is where I came from.
They're too stupid.
They don't know anything.
Let's ignore them.
I'm lost!
I'm just running for it!
Is there anything in here?
It's a dead end!
They make a lot of noise.
They're really squeaky.
Time stop amulet.
No, this was where the balls were.
Wait, where do I go?
Oh my gosh.
I'm so lost.
No way.
I'm so lost, you guys.
I have no idea.
I have zero idea.
Wait, what's in here?
Excuse me!
What's in here?
This is where we got the frost, right?
Let's check out our beautiful lady.
Is there a map?
What?
That would be helpful for players if there were a map.
Don't you understand what replayability is?
There's more replayability if you get them lost.
Or not replayability, more playtime.
If they get really lost and have no idea where to go.
That's just simple game design.
It says map on the menu?
Did you really expect me to be able to read?
Come on now.
Where are we?
Okay, but the map, I'll be honest, was not very helpful.
The map didn't help me at all.
Okay, hold on.
Down...
Right...
Very bottom?
Okay, I gotta go to the bottom.
I'm in the top right, so I need to go down to the middle?
Wait.
Down...
Right...
I think.
Down...
Wait, is it left or right?
Oh, here?
I think I found it.
Here?
Is this where I needed to be?
This door?
This is not a door.
Oh, I have to interact with it.
Oh my god.
Because it's the elevator.
Where's our ice babe?
Stay down!
Ouch.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Oh shoot.
Nevermind, we're fine.
Does it look goofy with this angle?
It's always goofy.
I proved my point!
I absolutely proved my point!
Dante, do you have nothing to say about this?
Don't speak.
Oh yeah!
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, okay, okay.
Dodge.
And he's icy.
Oh my god.
Wait, what the hell?
No!
And I can't... Oh, I can.
Oh, but it does nothing.
Oh my god, it does nothing to them.
Maybe?
I can't tell.
Here we go.
Nice.
That did decent damage at least.
Dodge!
Oh well, how am I supposed to know to dodge that?
Oh my gosh.
Like, we're the land.
How am I supposed to know?
I hate these ones.
Yeah, stupid!
Am I even doing damage?
Ouch, ouch, ouch!
Yes, I am kind of, I think.
No!
Gosh, how am I supposed to avoid that?
Wait, I think I did too early.
I did it too early!
Only for a little bit, but a little bit is... A little bit is better, I guess, than none.
Oh my gosh.
These guys
suck.
But they're actually not so bad.
For now.
Oh my gosh, I say, until...
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, how am I supposed to avoid that?
Please.
Please, so close.
Dead.
Anything else in here?
Who was that guy?
Just some dude.
Wait, is there anything around here?
Nothing?
OK, let's go in.
Check the chair.
It's so huge and I'm so teeny tiny.
Rafi!
Thank you for the gift.
Nice.
We're so close, guys.
I'm starting to get hungry for dinner.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, did I already do it?
Yeah, I think so.
OK, there we go.
What mission are we on?
17!
Oh my god.
Yeah!
Evil must be opposed and destroyed.
I have 8000.
What can I get?
I almost kind of want to get... Maybe like some vital stars?
I don't know, since I have nothing.
And some...
Some devil stars.
Stars might save your ass.
I agree.
It went up in price!
You asshole!
Oh my god!
It's so expensive!
Alrighty.
Let's go.
You hear that?
It's my controller.
Why doesn't he have any voice?
Like, why didn't he make any sound?
It's power!
He's giving Disney... Disney villain.
There's one Disney villain that sounds just like that.
Laffy!
Thanks for the gifted!
Like Jafar or something.
You!
Oh he gave you the sexy coin.
Nice!
A false coin.
Heads or tails?
Oh yeah!
Oh ok.
Wait...
Who am I fighting?
I can't see anything.
Oh ok.
Oh my goodness, good thing I drove.
Wait, who are these people?
Who are these guys?
Where's the guy I'm supposed to be fighting?
I thought I was fighting him.
Oh he's taking his little nap.
Ok, understandable.
Oh yeah, you're trying to...
Ok, there is backup dancers.
Let's just take these guys and get more DT.
Oh, ouch ouch.
I don't know what hit me, but something did.
Oh, him.
He's shooting at me.
Golly's guy, I think.
And then he summons more.
And then I dodge them.
And he sometimes... Oh my gosh.
He's got his little jesters.
What is this?
Why are there clowns all of a sudden?
This doesn't fit his image at all.
This is so stupid.
Oh, dang it.
You know what?
Screw it.
Ah, ok.
Alright, he's gonna summon more, but...
I wanna take these guys out.
I don't know if he can summon more of these guys.
Ouch, ouch ouch.
It does?
You think clowns suit this guy?
You see this man and you're just like...
Oh, ok.
Let's not use the sword.
Arius is just on the other side of the screen like, I'm bored.
Ok.
At least we're getting more stuff.
I just... Oh, we took one down.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, nevermind.
I was gonna say we took two down.
Oh, stop, stop, stop.
Ok, I think he can only summon in the monkeys.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
Oh gosh, please.
I'm trying to get rid of as many... Oh my gosh.
I'm trying to get rid of as many enemies as possible.
Like these guys especially.
Ok.
So then we can go and focus on him.
Oh my god.
Jake, thanks for the five gift.
Oh, shoot.
Where did he go?
Surely somewhere I'll be able to see him.
Oh, there he is.
No!
Leave him alone!
There we go.
You're not sitting down anymore, right?
Oh, you shot me in the air.
I don't like that.
That's ok, he's almost dead.
My life!
I was going to be king.
King!
I
was going to be king!
Guys, we are so close!
Let's go!
Here's your crown.
Yeah, I did.
Then...
What's that?
What?
Who are you talking about?
You literally told us that at the beginning of the game.
You told us that at the beginning of the game.
Is that supposed to be a twist?
I can't.
What's that twist?
So this game isn't very good.
I'm having fun.
Oh no, is it another cosmic space final battle event again?
I probably didn't expect anyone to pay attention to the story.
Are we going to be fighting together?
These in-game cutscenes versus the rendered ones that are really pixelated.
It's so funny.
She's crying.
It's a single tear.
How do you know?
You don't know that you could become a demon, no?
I like the music.
So romantic.
Oh my gosh.
It's the same on both sides.
Don't you want to hear the story about Sparda?
Mission 18.
The hunter shall surpass all who came before him.
Wait, how much money?
I could get a blorb.
How stacked realistically do I need to be for this fight, you guys?
Realistically how stacked?
I like Lucia's design and gameplay, but she's shackled to this game sadly.
Also, now you have to play as her to truly... No.
Anybody who tells me that I haven't truly beaten the game...
When I beat the game...
It's just... It's just an asshole.
I love how it's nothing, honestly, and the final boss is actually challenging.
We're right next to each other.
Vtuber is a DMC gamer?
How many other Vtubers have played DMC2?
How many gamers, how many people that are fans of Devil May Cry have actually played DMC2?
Final boss is the only well-designed enemy in the whole game.
Guys, I came in here... I think maybe some people misunderstand a little bit.
I came in to understand why people don't like DMC2.
I'm not here to complete DMC2.
I think we're fine for now.
We'll see.
If I have to come back... If I die, I die.
I'm so hungry though.
My tummy is growling.
Am
I here for the finale?
Oh my god.
Oh.
Argosax.
Wait, it's this guy from before.
Oh my gosh.
No way.
Wait, which boss did I hate the most?
Oh no.
I don't understand how to avoid this one.
Watch along of Lucia's cutscenes.
Maybe.
Maybe we can do that.
Oh my gosh.
Tonight.
Oh my god.
But I'm also really hungry.
I've never seen green before.
Wait.
Oh.
What's happening?
Oh, he's gone.
He's gone.
Which one was this one?
Oh, this is the monkey.
But you can't... Oh my gosh.
Oh, ouch.
Okay, you have to give me a chance to shoot monkey, okay?
We can't double up.
No, no.
Monkey time right now.
Right now is monkey time.
Thanks for the super chat.
I can't read them right now though.
Thank you, but I can't read them.
Oh, is he down?
Okay.
And then he melts.
Argo sucks.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, alright.
We have a little second, a little break.
Break.
Oh my gosh.
Which guy is this?
Oh, this is phantom.
Oh, shit.
Oh, three this time.
Getting fancy.
I tried, I tried, don't fade.
I was too slow.
I got it this time.
Okay.
Oh, nevermind.
Canceled.
Argo sucks!
Stupid!
Oh, nevermind.
Wow, that was horrible timing on my part.
Oh no.
Okay, let's do this one.
Oh god.
I hate.
What?
There's a grorb all the way over there.
There is.
Oh my gosh.
I think it's just the tentacle.
If it's just the tentacle...
I don't feel so bad about it, I think.
Wait, can he even reach me?
Can he even reach me?
Am I doing damage?
Guys, I couldn't tell if I was doing damage.
Oh, the thing is shaking, so I guess so.
But it's shaking.
Oh my god!
The bait!
I thought he was dead!
I am doing damage.
Yeah, it's just going down really slow.
I honestly can't remember the other two guys.
I can't remember who that fire guy is at all.
This is just ridiculous.
I'm just jumping and shooting.
Oops.
Too high of a jump.
Jumping and shooting.
I don't think he can reach me.
As long as I jump, I feel at least safe.
Let's try.
The oil rig.
That guy, that's right.
No way.
Wait, I beat him before by being really far away, so what do I do here?
Just kidding.
I don't remember this.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
This is... this is...
What was his name?
Griffin?
From the first game.
Oh my god.
That was close.
Ouch!
Okay.
Screw it!
Just take the hits!
Oh, we did it.
Now what?
The brain.
Phase 2?
Okay.
They just made everybody sexy in this game, huh?
No!
No, don't take her boobs!
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
I'm not doing any damage.
Oh, her boobs are back.
Oh my gosh.
Please, please.
Oh my god.
What?
Guys, I don't want to have to redo phase 1.
I really don't want to have to do that again.
Oh, shoot.
Damn it.
Okay.
Ouch!
I don't want to use it and waste it.
Damn, that didn't give me a whole ton.
But okay.
Ouch!
How do I avoid this?
Oh my god.
Wow, it was only one hour over the average.
It's not bad for me.
Damn.
Yay!
Thanks to the 5 Crystals.
The sword I never use.
Oh, yeah!
Why?
Where is this coming from?
If I held... What?
Why did I never use that before?
Jackpot!
And then you drive off into the... Hellscape?
Not the sunset?
That's it?
I like the music here.
Well guys, that was a game.
Canonically, now he just sort of chills in hell.
Or does some other stuff for a while.
Hooray!
Just got back from the toilet.
What did I miss?
Nothing much.
Oh, my bad.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
Charlie, welcome to membership.
And Alexander, thank you for the pink.
Guys, I must not be a devil because...
I'm crying.
What do
you mean that's it?
Now I understand why people hate this game.
Yuma, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Peter, thanks for 7 months.
You went through all that and they couldn't even give you a decent ending.
Have a dessert, Minky.
Thank you for the Minky.
Congrats on finishing your torture session.
Feel like a DMC fan now, Minto?
I gotta play the other games.
I'm just doing them in order.
Win Lucia disc?
Lucia?
Gosh, I always call her Lucia.
Lucia.
We'll see.
I might record myself playing it.
And then upload it while I'm gone.
Maybe.
Today's my birthday, can I get a...
Wondering if I can get a happy birthday from my Oshi.
Mr. Yamiya, happy birthday!
Oh my gosh, wait, there's multiple birthdays.
Soma, happy birthday!
First, we'll do Soma.
Demonstrate.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Soma.
One more time!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Mr. Yamiya.
Happy birthday!
It's funny because...
I'll see people being like...
Lucia has no...
Narrative significance.
And then other people being like...
Lucia's route is faster.
Lucia's route is way slower.
And just so many mixed messages.
I never know if you guys are trying to get me to play it.
Because you're like...
There's actually more information if you play her route.
Or if it's like...
We want you to suffer.
And we're gaslighting you into playing it.
I've been wondering...
If you're playing all of the Devil May Cry games...
Does that include DMC?
Or are we ignoring the reboot?
Probably...
I have no plans to play it for right now.
The actual ending is only shown when you beat both campaigns.
I see.
I don't believe you.
That's the thing.
I actually don't believe you.
I'm sorry.
Like, people say so many things.
I just don't believe it.
Congrats on beating the Valley of DMC.
It's an uphill from here.
Wait, isn't... No.
It should be a downhill.
We went uphill.
Villain, uphill is the hard part.
And then it's the downhill that's the good part.
Right?
It's all downhill from here.
I think you mean uphill.
You're thinking uphill as in like it gets better.
Because you're going up.
But it's the opposite.
Now that you beat DMC2 as Dante, you can play as Trish.
Trish?
Wait, Trish?
This?
Well, that happened.
A summary of DMC2.
Still a fun stream.
Thanks to you, Minto.
Thank you.
Downhill is bad.
No.
When people say it's all downhill from here...
It means that it's easier, right?
Or rather...
Things get...
Because nobody...
Imagine you're riding a bike.
You're riding a bike and you're going uphill.
And you're just like...
It's hard.
And then when you go downhill, you're just like...
This is so easy.
It's so easy.
We're not on a bike though.
It's the metaphor.
We're not actually going downhill either.
All downhill from here saying it's completely out of control.
Wait, did I try mansplaining?
Wait, am I wrong?
Are you going to die on that hill?
Am I wrong?
But I've always heard...
Wait, but I've heard when it's all downhill from here, it's better.
I'm mansplaining.
I'm wrong!
If you're saying it gets easier, downhill is better.
If you're saying it gets better, uphill is better.
Both work in different contexts.
Okay.
Only DFC game where pistols are strong.
You can play as Trish if you finish on hard.
It didn't give me an option to choose a difficulty.
The DFC games from here are way better.
Yeah.
In my defense, the saying it's all downhill from here meant bad things.
Maybe it's regional.
I don't know.
No, villain.
I'm sorry.
You sent me such a nice super chat.
And I was just like, no, you're wrong!
Immediately.
I apologize.
I sincerely actually apologize.
I'm so sorry.
I can admit when I have goofed.
You're right.
But people misuse it so often that a lot of people don't get it.
Wait, I'm right?
I don't know anything anymore.
It's like, oh my gosh.
Maybe it's similar to the whole...
Okay, one thing.
Thanks, dry princess!
It's like a snowball going downhill.
One thing that's been like such an...
Something that annoys me so much is on TikTok.
Which, you know, already...
Starting off strong.
People will say POV...
Something, something, something.
You know, like, POV...
You are talking to me...
And I...
Um...
I'm hyperfixated.
I'm telling you about my hyperfixation.
But they don't understand what POV means.
It's not a POV.
Kids don't know what POV means anymore.
They don't understand that it's...
Point of view.
It's so actually frustrating.
That I'm like, no...
POV would be from my eyes.
Like, that doesn't make any sense.
Oh my gosh, it actually drives me insane.
You're right.
I blame Newfound Glory for this confusion.
Who's Newfound Glory?
Wait, isn't that a band?
The...
De-evolution of language.
It's just so frustrating.
But like, so...
Often I see it...
That...
In the past, I used to see people being like...
This is not what a POV is.
But I think people have just given up.
Like...
I think people have just given up.
It's so bad.
Am I out of touch?
No, it's actually not.
It's not out of touch, though.
Because it's like...
Actually just inaccurate.
I absolutely despise...
The rampant misuse of POV.
Maybe this is my...
Get off my lawn, kids moment.
But I don't care.
You know what, I will die on this uphill.
I will...
This is the uphill...
Oh, wait.
This is the uphill I will die on.
Now you guys say, what's uphill?
What's uphill?
Oh wait, hold on.
It's all...
Uphill from here.
Hank Hill?
Wait.
What's the guys from...
King of the Hill?
Hank Hill, right?
Yeah?
Okay.
So you're saying like...
What's uphill?
You're saying, what's up, Hank Hill?
I'm firing you into orbit so there are no hills.
You'll have to catch me first.
Your name isn't Hill.
It could be.
I could change my last name.
Chat, mine is too hard.
No!
When you are small like me though, every bump on the road is a hill to die on.
Guys, I think I'm gonna go eat dinner because it's getting kind of late for me.
This is fun.
Thank you guys for...
We finally experienced...
We did it!
One and done, baby!
We went and done...
Devil May Cry.
Next on to...
Devil May Cry 3.
POV, you're a wisp listening to me ramble.
Stop!
Sofa!
Oh my gosh!
Welcome to Babushan!
Thank you!
Happy birthday again!
Okey dokey.
Alright.
Good game.
Have a good game.
Your mind will be blown by 3.
I'm excited.
Very excited.
I haven't felt like any DMC brain rot so much.
Except...
I do quote the...
LIE!
thing quite often.
I was supposed to seal your soul with a lie!
So yeah.
We'll start...
How long is DMC 3?
Oh, sorry.
Hold on.
I think...
How long to beat Devil May Cry 3?
Oh, okay.
So, like, a couple streams.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's no problem.
Yeah, that's no problem.
Oh, good.
20 missions.
Okay.
Cool.
Yeah, I'm thinking...
Depending on how far I get...
Like...
3 streams.
Sometimes it depends.
I'll be expecting to do 3 streams with a stream.
Or with a game.
And then I'm like...
I'm so tired.
I can only go on for so long.
Okay.
Otsumito, everybody!
Thank you.
We finally...
We beat this.
We can cross it off the books.
Otsumito!
Thank you, guys.
I will see you...
Whenever...
Tomorrow I'm playing Metal Gear.
I was gonna say...
Supreme Game Series.
That might wrestle some jimmies, I think.
Thanks for the superchat!
But it will be ghost babble.
So I'm very, very excited.
One that I have not played yet.
So, exciting.
Otsumito, everybody!
Have a good night, have a good day.
And I'll see you guys next time.
Bye bye!
Oh!
Stool of Chains!
Oh my god!
Look at him!
Wow!
Oh my gosh!
Yeah, baby!
Is that an ass guy?
Or is that like a...
Why is he so...
Like...
Like he's so...
OK, bye!